[Music]
hello everyone
today we're going to talk about aws in
10 minutes
let's look at the agenda here
let's talk about what aws is
why it's such a big hit
we'll have a look at the overview of the
services we'll see how much it costs
how big it is and what the future of aws
is
so
what is aws
everyone is talking about amazon web
services but let's have a look at what
it is
it's basically a global cloud platform
which allows you to host and manage
services on the internet
it's used by almost 80 percent of
fortune 500 companies to host their
infrastructure and it has a lot of
services which it provides to its
customers
there's infrastructure service which
means they provide bare servers as a
service so you don't need to manage the
backup and the power supply of the
service
they provide platform of the service
you can get java ruby php as a service
so that you don't have to manage the
binaries of these applications
you get software as a service wherein
you get email sending capabilities like
ses
you get queuing services like sqs and
it's a cloud storage platform wherein
you have a lot of storage options
including ebs and s3 so all in all aws
is a hosting provider which gives you a
lot of services wherein you can run your
applications on the cloud
now let's take a look at why it's such a
big hit
so everyone is trying to use aws
everyone is trying to put their
applications on the cloud
so what's the reason that aws is the top
provider and the top choice for doing
anything on the cloud
one of the biggest reasons is the
billing so the billing is very clear you
get a per hour billing
every instance or every service has a
micro billing so be it instances on ec2
you get per hour billing rate which is
very transparent
even s3 buckets are charged on a per gb
basis although it is a storage service
but still there is micro billing
available there
the sign up process is easy
you don't need to sign any agreement
nothing you just go sign up with an
email id add a credit card and you're
good to go
you can go from zero to one hundred in
just two minutes
you can launch your servers big machines
without buying hardware without
procuring any hardware you can just be
up and running in minutes
so their billing dashboard is also very
simple
they give you an integrated billing
dashboard which gives you reports
you can pull out reports every month you
can pull out reports based on services
based on various parameters
[Music]
for the cloud provider to be a hit you
need it to be stable it has to be a
trusted thing
so their services are quite stable
in the last seven or eight years they
have seen some three or four major
outages but those have been only region
specific
so that means out of the 12 or 13
regions in which they operate the
outages have been region specific in a
particular country or continent and
those also have not been more than two
or three hours and have not affected all
of their customers
it's a trusted vendor so when we talk
about aws it comes up as something which
is used by everyone in the industry
from small startups to big enterprises
everyone sees amazon as a trusted
advisor
now let's have an overview of the most
commonly used services
so the first and the most commonly used
service is ec2 which is elastic compute
cloud
this is the service which gives you bare
servers
so this service will give you a machine
which you can launch and you can run
your software on those
you can get small or big machines based
on your requirements
the second choice is vpc
so amazon will not allow you full
control of their cloud instead they give
you chunks of their cloud which is vpc
or the virtual private cloud
so vpc lets you create networks in the
cloud and then run your servers in those
networks
the next one is s3 which is simple
storage service
so s3 gives you the opportunity to
upload and share files so it is mostly a
file storage and sharing service
then you've got rds which is relational
database service
so this rds allows you to run and manage
databases on the cloud so they've got
almost all the major flavors of
databases right from sql server to
oracle and mysql postgresql
they've recently launched another one
which is called aurora which claims to
be a very high performance database
then route 53 is there for dns so
they've got a managed dns service
wherein you can point your dns to amazon
and they take care of the stuff
so it's a global dns service it's a
scalable dns service so it scales
according to demand
there's also elastic load balancer the
elb is a service which gives you the
opportunity to load balance incoming
traffic to multiple machines so this way
you can skill up your web applications
to any number of users
you've got auto scaling which adds
capacity on the fly to elastic load
balancers so that your website or your
application is never down due to a load
how much does it cost
this per our billing is already
mentioned for everything if it's
something like a storage thing again
there's a per hour or per gb month
storage
so i think there is region specific
pricing so virginia is the cheapest
region out of all of them
so the region specific pricing is
because they have got some regions which
they have got good hold of and they are
the headquarters so oregon and virginia
are the cheapest actually
they also give you services based on the
term so if you sign up for something for
a year it would be cheaper for you
rather than signing up for something on
an on-demand basis so they've got
reserved instances which are very cheap
as compared to the on-demand ones you
can get discounts from twenty percent to
almost sixty percent if you sign up for
a three-year term
they are spot resources examples of
these are spot instances
so this is like a bidding market base
where you can bid for a price
the only downside of this kind of
pricing is that your machine might be
terminated or your resources might be
terminated if someone bids higher
people use these kind of things for
doing some ad hoc in search or some ad
hoc tasks which are really not critical
how big is it
they have got 15 regions across major
countries of the world
they've got regions in the us europe
asia pacific
they've got a global footprint so in
today's world if you are anywhere in the
world you would have a region within 1
000 miles of your location they've got
massive data centers so each of the
region has got multiple availability
zones so one availability zone can be
thought of as a big data center
the data centers have anywhere from 300
000 to 500 000 servers
what is the future of aws
so they currently have 64 services which
span across infrastructural service
software as a service platform as a
service
they are launching new services in all
demands every day
right now they are focusing on machine
learning so recently they've launched a
couple of services which focus
exclusively on machine learning and they
are focusing on software as a service
product wherein they want to take
control of the service you want to
utilize
they don't want you to do it they want
you to upload it to them
and every now and then they keep on
reducing the costs so you would hear it
in the blog that okay the price of ec2
machines has been reduced
and this is because of their scale so
they scale up and they give the cost
benefit to the customer
today we will be discussing all about
aws and its impact in 2021 so let's get
started
according to o'reilly more than 90
percent of organizations are expected to
increase their cloud infrastructure in
2021 the upshot is that the majority of
cloud users plan to scale their business
and cloud rather than reducing their
cloud usage share the code 19 pandemic
led organizations to increasingly shift
to the cloud which helped them improve
business continuity official meetings
like video conferencing were done on the
cloud using apps as google meet zoom etc
now let me give you a brief description
on what cloud computing is cloud
computing helps users to store access
and manage data by logging in from their
devices via the internet instead of
storing data on their hard drives cloud
computing gives the ability to manage
applications and services through the
internet
let's see what gartner says about cloud
infrastructure and platform services
for your information gartner is the
famous iit service management company
across the world
gartner's magic quadrant report for
cloud infrastructure and platform
services noted that the capability gap
between hyperscale cloud providers has
begun to narrow however fierce
competition for enterprise workloads
extends to secondary markets worldwide
the famous cloud providers in the market
are aws microsoft azure and google cloud
all of which have been strong
aws or amazon web services has been
known for its rapid pace of innovation
in cloud computing and this year is no
different aws is the leader in public
cloud providers and has a more
significant impact on modern
technologies like machine learning
robotics and iot amazon web services is
an online service provider that offers
various services such as compute power
storage database content delivery and
other resources to help businesses scale
and grow
these services are provided based on a
subscription basis
talking about the general features
amazon web services was found in the
year 2006 and apparently it holds a
market share of 31.7
aws provides approximately 175 fully
featured services
it consists of significant benefits like
compute storage databases networking
analytics robotics machine learning
artificial intelligence etc
now let us know the five primary reasons
why aws is essential and how it can
influence your business amazon web
services has various benefits that make
users rely on them
firstly it allows you to set up a
virtual office which will reduce the
cost of maintaining and monitoring your
infrastructure
secondly compared to the on-premises
environment aws provides a high level of
data protection and a lower cost to its
users
thirdly based on the requirement you
receive you can scale up or scale down
your resources
fourthly in case you face a power
failure or any crisis having your files
stored in the cloud ensures it is backed
up and secured in a safe location
and lastly in short aws offers high
scalable services for database data
warehousing transcoding storage backup
infrastructure management application
management etc which helps in reducing
the overall time and effort spent in
setting up and managing the
infrastructure
now let's take a step back and look at
the history of aws
amazon web services was the first online
service provider to introduce a psu go
pricing model in cloud computing
aws was launched in 2006 with three
services amazon ec2 aws s3 cloud storage
and sqs
now let us discuss how much the
companies have saved with the help of
aws
this shows a tremendous benefit of using
aws
aws continues to lower the cost of the
cloud for its customers
compared to on-premise infrastructure
when a web application is deployed on
aws companies save 76 of the total
expense
companies save over 50 by running
business applications by consuming aws
resources
aws is the world's most broadly adopted
cloud platform many companies like espn
adobe twitter netflix facebook bbc etc
use aws
adobe quickly creates and updates
software without depending upon the it
teams it utilizes its services by
offering multi-terabyte operating
environments for its clients
by deploying its services with amazon
adobe integrated and operated its
software in a simple manner
a lot of people don't know the reason
for aws being so popular to understand
the popularity of aws you need to look
at these numbers first
first is cost
aws costs keep declining aws has
decreased its service price as many as
60 times since its launch
aws saves 76 of the expenditure of
running a standard web application and
reduces the processing cost by 50
percent
one-third of people who visit websites
on daily basis access sites powered by
aws
aws has customers over 190 countries
worldwide including 5000 edtech
institutions and 2000 government
organizations
31 percent of cloud infrastructure as a
market share service belongs to aws
while 10 belongs to microsoft and 7 to
ibm
aws has more than 1 million users in 190
countries
now let's discuss the revenue growth of
aws
according to gartner amazon retained the
number one position in the ias market in
2019 followed by microsoft and google
amazon continued to stay on top of the
ias market worldwide with an estimated
20 billion dollars of revenue in 2019
and 96.1 billion in 2020.
as of february report canalis confirms
aws has a total market share of 31
whereas microsoft holds a share up to 20
microsoft maintained number two position
in the ias platform with more than half
of its nearly eight billion dollars in
revenue
according to the canalis diagram shown
on your screen amazon leveraged its
number one position in the cloud market
continuously from 2019 to 2020 by
offering complete and unique services in
the cloud stack
in q2 2020 a prediction of profit in aws
was expected to reach 88.9 billion
dollars but surprisingly due to covet 19
the company saw quarterly sales increase
to 88.9 billion dollars
the net income of 5.2 billion dollars
was the highest in a single quarter
while microsoft azure has seen revenue
growth of 47 over the previous quarter
the report has a revenue growth number
of various cloud providers
aws is continuously adding new features
to utilize the updated services to
improve the productivity of work more
quickly
let's discuss each service one by one
at number one amazon cloudfront supports
origin shield amazon has updated its
cloudfront service with a shield feature
that increases cache capacity and
decreases the load on your origin
next aws im supports aws private link
which means it can invoke lambda
functions into a virtual private cloud
by eliminating network traffic to the
public internet
thirdly amazon sns supports fifo in
sequence
amazon sns introduces first in first out
topics intended for customers to process
messages across multiple services in a
sequenced manner
amazon sns fifo is available in 22 aws
regions
next aws dms functionality supports
amazon document db
amazon document db has the
responsibility of storing querying and
indexing data with aws database
migration service support
dms helps in migrating databases to aws
environments quickly
next amazon chime sdk now supports
health monitoring and troubleshooting
developers can now collect client
metrics from meeting events available
from the amazon chime sdk for javascript
finally aws server migration service now
adds support for application monitoring
using amazon cloudwatch application
insights
you can start monitoring applications in
amazon cloudwatch as soon as the
application migration is complete in aws
sms
there are plenty of cloud jobs that can
help you grow in your career
tech republic says in the past few
months job seekers are hunting for cloud
computing roles on indeed website
cloud computing job roles such as cloud
infrastructure cloud security cloud
architect and cloud engineer had risen
nearly by 108
employer interest for candidates with
cloud computing skills rose by 33
percent
now let's look at who an aw solutions
architect is and what they do
an aws solutions architect is
responsible for deploying your
applications on the aws platform
ever since cloud computing has come into
the limelight companies and
organizations worldwide have started to
migrate their physical infrastructure to
the cloud this is where aws solutions
architects come in they help in
relocating the physical infrastructure
to the aws cloud aws solutions architect
is responsible for creating a design
with the detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure they plan to set up
they are required to focus on
non-functional requirements such as
usability reliability scalability and
cloud infrastructure performance
aws solutions architects are responsible
for minimizing business risks such as
security leaks calculation mistakes and
even application downtime risks
every aws solutions architect must
ensure that none of these problems
happen
a lot of people must be wondering how
much a solution architect and a cloud
engineer earns
the average salary of a solution
architect in india is rupees 18 lakhs 36
996 per year and in the united states
they earn 128 000 per annum whereas a
cloud engineer in india earns 12 lakh 41
000 rupees per annum and in the united
states they earn 139 000 440 dollars per
annum
now that you know about aws and its
important concepts time for a small quiz
which of the following is an online
backup and storage system
option a amazon simple storage system
aws s3 option b aws cloud formation
option c amazon elastic compute cloud
aws ec2 and option d both a and c
let us know what you think is a right
answer in the comments below in cloud
computing the competition for leadership
is a quite tough three-way race
amazon web services
microsoft azure and google cloud
platform clearly are the top cloud
companies who are commanding lead in the
infrastructure as a service and platform
as service markets
in this video we will compare and
contrast aws azure and gcp based on a
few related concepts around these cloud
computing platforms
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top cloud platforms
and will also let us figure out the
individuality of each one of them
but before starting with the comparison
let's have a quick introduction of aws
versus azure versus gcp
so let's get started
amazon web services or aws is a cloud
computing platform that manages and
maintains hardware and infrastructure
reducing the expense and complexity of
purchasing and running resources on-site
for businesses and individuals
these resources are available for free
or for a fee per usage
microsoft azure is a cloud computing
service that it offers a collection of
cloud computing services for building
testing deploying and managing
application in the cloud including
remotely hosted and managed versions of
microsoft technology google cloud
platform offers a variety of cloud
computing services for building
deploying scaling monitoring and
operating a cloud
the services are identical to those that
power google products such as google
search gmail youtube and google drive
now let's move on to the comparison
between aws assure and gcp
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like
origin
service integration
availability zone
cloud tools like compute
storage
networking
market share
pricing
and at last who uses them
now
let's move ahead and start with the
first comparison origin
in the year 2006 amazon web services aws
was introduced to the market
and in the year 2010
ashore launched its services
whereas on the other hand gcp was
established in the year 2008.
from the start aws has been supportive
of the open source concept but the open
source community has a tense
relationship with azure
on the other hand gcp similar to aws
provides google cloud with manage open
source services that are tightly linked
aws offers services on a large and
complex scale that can be manipulated
but azure support is comparatively low
quality
whereas gcp's monthly support price is
almost 150 dollars for the silver class
which is the most basic of services and
is quite expensive
now let's move on to the service
integration of these cloud platforms
service integration is a set of tools
and technology that connects different
applications systems
repositories and data and process
interchange in real time
aws makes it simple for users to combine
services such as amazon ec2 amazon s3
beanstalk and others
on the other hand azure allows customers
to effortlessly combine azure vms
as your app service sql databases and
other services
whereas users can utilize gcp to combine
services such as compute engine
cloud storage and cloud sql
now that we know briefly about all these
cloud platforms let's have a look at the
availability zones of these platforms
because aws was the first in the cloud
domain they have had more time to build
and extend their network
but
azure and gcp both have various
locations around the world
but the distinction is in the amount of
availability zones they have
aws now offers 66 availability zones
with an additional 12 on the pipeline
close to it azure is available in 140
countries and is available in 54 regions
throughout the world
but google cloud platform is now
available in 20 global areas with three
more on the way
now let's move on to the next important
factor which is tools
now let's move ahead and have have a
look at the first feature
which is compute
elastic compute cloud or ec2 is aws
compute service which offers a wide
range of features including a large
number of instances
support for both windows and linux high
performance computing and
more as sure on the other hand virtual
machines is microsoft azure's core
cloud-based compute solution
it includes linux windows server and
other operating systems as well as
better security and microsoft program
integration
in comparison to its competitors
google's computing services catalog is
somewhat smaller
compute engine that companies principal
service offers custom and pre-defined
machine types
per second invoicing linux and windows
support and carbon neutral
infrastructure that uses half the energy
of traditional data centers
within the compute category amazon's
different containers services are
gaining prominence it has docker
kubernetes and it's also fargate service
which automates server and cluster
management when using containers as well
as other alternatives
azure unlike aws uses virtual machine
scale sets of two container services
azure container service is based on
kubernetes and container service
uses docker hub and azure container
registry for management
for enterprises interested in deploying
containers google offers the kubernetes
engine
it's also worth noting that google was
significantly involved in the kubernetes
project
providing it extensive knowledge in this
field
now let's move on to the next parameter
of comparison which is storage
simple storage service
for object storage elastic block storage
for persistent block storage and elastic
file system for file storage among aws
storage offerings
block storage for rest based object
storage of unstructured data queue
storage for a large volume workloads
file storage and disk storage are among
microsoft azure core storage services
gcp offers an increasing number of
storage options its unified object
storage service
cloud storage also has a persistent disk
option
relational database service or rds
dynamodb nosql database elastic cache in
memory data store red shift data
warehouse
neptune graph database and database
migration service are all sql compatible
databases
offered by amazon
the database choices in azure especially
wide
sql database mysql
database and postgre sql database are
the three sql based choices
when it comes to databases gcp offers
the sql based cloud sql and cloud
spanner a relational database built for
mission critical workloads
now the next parameter is networking
aws uses amazon virtual private cloud or
vpc
on the other hand azure uses
azure virtual network
we net
and gcp uses cloud virtual network
now let's move on to the another factor
which is market share and pricing
all these cloud services are based on
comparative pricing strategy which means
you need to pay on the basis of its
usage
according to canalis the worldwide cloud
market rose 35
to 41.8 billion in the first quarter of
2021.
aws accounts for 32 of the market
with azure accounting for 19
and google accounting for seven percent
on one hand amazon charges on a yearly
basis and on the other hand microsoft
azure and google services charge on a
minute basis and also
of them provide you a standard price for
you to access these services
aws charges roughly 69 per month for a
very basic instance with two virtual
cpus and 8gb of ram
and aws largest instance with 3.84 db of
ram and 128 vcpus will set you back
roughly 3.97
per r
but in azure the same type of instance
one with two v cpus and 8 gb of ram cost
roughly 70
us
per month
and asia's largest instance has 3.89 tb
of ram
and 128 virtual cpus
it costs about 6.79 per hour
compared to aws gcp will supply you with
the most basic instance which includes
two virtual cpus and eight gigabytes of
ram for 25 less
as a result it will set you back roughly
to 52
every month and the largest instance
that include
is 3.75 db of ram and 160v cpus it will
cost you around 5.32 dollar per hour
amazon other than this also provides
spot instances reserved instances and
dedicated host where you can look for
multiple offers and discounts
but for ensure it provides special
prices to developers based on situations
or even ensure hybrid benefit which
benefits your organization up to 40
percent if it uses microsoft software
in their data centers
whereas google offers quite a sorted
pricing to its customer compared to
other two
it gives you sustained use discounts
which activate if you use the same
instance for a month
the printable instance which is very
similar to amazon spot instances
but one thing is common in all three
cloud services which is they all offer
long term discount
now let's have a look at the last
comparison which is companies using them
because aws is the oldest player in the
cloud business
it has a largest user base and community
support as a result aws has the largest
number of high-profile and well-known
clients including netflix airbnb
unilever bmw samsung mi senga and others
with time azure is getting a large
number of high profile customers
azure currently boasts around 80 percent
of fortune
500 firms as customers johnson controls
polycom
fujifilm hp honeywell apple and others
are among its key clients
google cloud on the other hand uses the
same infrastructure as google search and
youtube and as a result many high in
enterprises
trust google cloud hsbc paper
20th century fox bloomberg domino's and
other among google clouds many clients
so
this was all about aws versus assure
versus gcp
hi there welcome to this brand new
learning video called cloud computing
tutorial i'm samuel a multi-platform
cloud architect and trainer working for
simply learn let's dive deep into the
topics we're going to discuss here why
we needed cloud computing to begin with
and what is cloud computing and
different types of cloud computings
available at the moment and we also are
going to talk about a dominant cloud
providers available in the market at the
moment and we will touch a few topics or
scenarios on lifecycle of a cloud
computing solution and we will be
talking about how cloud computing is
implemented in aws and there is nothing
like visually seeing how things work in
the cloud right so we're going to end it
with a demo and we're going to talk
about products or we're actually going
to use products like ec2 and s3 ec2
being a virtual computer in the cloud
and s3 being an object storage in the
cloud let's understand about why cloud
computing was needed what was the
problem that we had that cloud computing
solved and since then it took over the
market let's add a lot of unanswered
questions about cloud computing or
services that you might have here on the
left we have an owner of a business and
he wants to set up an dz or have an i.t
infrastructure for his company so he
called paul an i.t educated person in
his company and consulted him about how
to go about setting up an id
infrastructure now paul is the kind of
guy who keeps himself updated about
what's happening in the iit industry and
he frequently goes through learnings
about the reason technology so with
benefiting i'm going to explain to you
now let's start with the expenditure or
the billing model expect that we pay
everything upfront and there is an
additional operating cost and it never
lets us to dynamically scale in
on-premises a lot of space is required
for seating the servers but in the cloud
not such space requirement is needed for
the organization in on premises we also
need a dedicated team to manage the
hardware and software but in the cloud
no such dedicated team is needed for
most of the services they all get
managed by the provider and even if we
need to manage them the provider gives
us options to manage them through the
console which is lot lot simpler than
managing directly from the device in the
on premises we need to admit the fact
that data security is poor due to the
cost involved in procuring the hardware
and software to provide the security but
in the cloud the security standards are
high due to the investments the
providers have done to secure the data
and to meet the compliance in
traditional dc there will generally be
less focus on data recovery and we kind
of settle for less when it comes to data
recovery due to the cost involved and
you know the effort involved in
replicating the data and even if we set
up a high-performing data replication a
lot more can be done in the cloud for
the same cost the on-premises
environment lacks the flexibility needed
today like if i need to restructure the
it for the new age business needs then
the on-premises is not so friendly for
such changes but in the cloud i can
easily undo or tear down an environment
or migrate to the new environment and
tear down the old environment in few
button clicks now looking at the number
and the frequency of the releases that
happen scheduling updates would be an
full-time job but with cloud the updates
happen automatically in on-premises if
i'm working with the team that is spread
across the globe working with them in
unison and sharing the data is a tedious
work but with the cloud there are a lot
of tools and technologies put together
that makes it easy to share the data
with other members in the team or with
the new prospective customer in on
premises if i'm working with the team
that is spread across the globe working
with them in unison and sharing the data
is a tedious work but with a cloud there
are a lot of tools and technologies put
together that makes it easy to share the
data with other members in the team or
with a new prospect customer i will be
working with who is present across the
other side of the globe in on premises
the data will be present inside the dc
or inside the on-premises dc and even a
valid user trying to access the data
from outside the organization is a tough
task but with a cloud as long as someone
has internet providing the person access
is just a few mouse clicks away talk
about implementation building an
on-premises dc takes time i was working
on a project few years back and the goal
to make a dc go live at that time was
after two years from the date we were
speaking about it but with the cloud we
can bring our dc in the cloud within
weeks after all this explanation and
comparisons and talking about benefits
paul's manager was fully enlightened and
wants to have his id environment in the
cloud but our paul is not done yet and
he took his manager through another
level of discussion about the cloud just
like i'm gonna take you now so let's
talk about what is cloud computing now
cloud computing is the ability to
deliver on-demand computing service over
the internet and that too on a
pay-as-you-go basis now you might think
well what does that mean let me explain
now with cloud rather than managing
files on local storage devices cloud
computing makes it possible to save them
over the internet and access them from
the internet so i can be a mobile person
and i'm moving from place to place but i
can access the storage from the internet
because it's in the internet and if i
want to give access to somebody else
again it's easy for me to give access to
them as long as they have internet
connection available with them now let's
move further and talk about or get
understanding on the types of cloud
computing we can categorize the
different types of cloud computing based
on two white categories one being a
deployment model and the other one being
service model let's talk about the
deployment model first deployment model
is categorized into three types first
one is public and then private and then
hybrid cloud in other words public cloud
private cloud and hybrid cloud it'll be
easy for me to explain and also it'll be
easy for you to understand if i walk you
through this example consider the
different types of vehicles we use to
commute from one place to another for
example if i want to travel i can pick a
bus which is accessible to anyone i get
in and i pay for the seat that i occupy
and i pay for the time that i will be
traveling in it and i'm done cost is
very less here a similar kind of thing
happens in the public cloud i pay only
for the resource that i use and i pay
for how long i use it if i use less i
pay less if i use more i pay more for
that month simple on the other hand
private cloud is like buying your own
car and using it for commuting purpose
here i pay a huge amount upfront and it
is all owned only by me i do not pay for
it in an hourly fashion but completely
and all up front the cost here is very
huge and thirdly if i want the best of
both types like the comfort of the own
car and still don't want to pay all
upfront otherwise one only to pay for
the time that i use the service i can
rent a car similarly i can have it in a
hybrid environment meaning if i already
have a dc i can integrate it with the
cloud and use both the dc's and that
would become an hybrid environment all
right so that was good often uh learning
let's summarize the types of cloud based
on deployment models and as we know now
about the public cloud public cloud is
an cloud infrastructure that's made
available to the general public over the
internet and it is owned by the cloud
provider some of the major players as
cloud providers are aws microsoft azure
ibm's blue cloud and suncloud and
private cloud now this cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization it can be
managed by organizations or third party
and may exist on premises or
off-premises doesn't matter but the
point here is this is exclusively
operated for a single organization and
some companies that provide private
cloud are aws and vmware and hybrid
cloud gives the best of both public and
the private cloud for example the
federal agencies they opt for private
clouds for storing and developing
personal data and they use public cloud
to share the non-sensitive data with the
general public or with other government
departments
now let's talk about different clouds
based on the service model if we need to
categorize them broadly we can
categorize them as infrastructure as a
service ias or platform as a service
paas or software as a service sas they
sometimes are referred to as i as pass
and says now at this moment you could be
like this guy thinking sam i thought
you'd done categorizing the cloud now
you're going to talk about three more
categories which one should i pick well
let me explain if all that you want is
just a vm and you have all the expertise
to install the software on top of it and
make it work then go for is if you only
want a platform or an interface to
program or an interface to upload a
program and make it run then pick pass
or if all that you want is a finished
product hosted in the cloud and be able
to access it through the internet then
go for sas here you get a username and
password for an application and you can
begin to customize the application based
on your needs all right let's talk about
is in a bit more detail is it gives
basic computing infra it's based on uh
pay for what you use model and some of
the cloud providers who are big players
are aws azure and google and here the
users generally will be id admins in
pass the provider gives you a platform
or a runtime environment for developing
testing and managing application it's
platform ready you buy the platform you
upload a code and you start working on
it and it allows the software developers
to deploy applications without running
the underlying infrastructure and as you
might have guessed by now the
interesting candidates who would use paz
is software developers and in sas
everything is managed by the vendor be
it the hardware or the software it's
managed by the vendor and we pay for the
service and we pay for it through a pay
as you go subscription model and as you
might have guessed the end users here
would be end customer itself all right
let's put together everything in the
same page and compare and contrast the
different types of service models in
this chart it explains the difference
between the four models starting from
on-premises to is and then pass and says
it is self-explanatory that the
resources managed by us are huge in on
premises and little less in is and
further less or reduced in pass and
nothing to manage when it comes to sas
let me also explain the different types
of cloud services through an example
like this let's say that you have a
crush on cake and you're planning to
bake one yourself now let's look at the
options you can have you can make all
the ingredients yourself be the floor
butter and you know put together and
bake the whole thing yourself using your
own oven pan you know the needed water
and the rest you get idea right
everything is yours and that's on
premises all that you use is owned by
you and nothing is managed by the vendor
the other options you can have is buy
the ingredients and mix and bake the
cake yourself now this would be like is
here the infra is managed by the
provider and we get to use it and
customize it the way we want it here the
cloud service is then shared
responsibility the other options you
still have on hand is simply pick a
phone and order a cake now this is a lot
simpler than the rest we discussed so
far you know it's simply picking the
phone and ordering the cake and pay for
it when it arrives simple and when it
reaches home you will have to arrange
the table garnish the cake if that's
needed and then enjoy the cake it's the
same way with pass just get the platform
in which you would run your code and
upload your code and start running your
application here you and the vendor
still share the responsibility you still
have one more option left that is simply
go out and dine this is a lot lot
simpler that it requires no effort from
us at all you buy the fully finished and
garnished cake and pay for it and walk
out no responsibility on making the cake
it's the same way with sass we buy the
finished product and pay for the
finished application as next thing let's
talk about the different cloud providers
amazon web services aws is a cloud
computing service provided by amazon it
provides a mix of infrastructure as a
service is platform as a service pass
and package software as a service called
sas offerings microsoft azure formerly
known as windows assure is a cloud
computing service by microsoft and it
sort of specializes in using cloud for
building testing deploying and managing
the applications through the servers
throughout the global network that
microsoft manages it also provides
software as a service platform as a
service infrastructure as a service and
it supports lots of different
programming languages and tools and
frameworks including both microsoft and
third-party software and systems ibm
cloud is a cloud computing service
offered by ibm ibm cloud includes
infrastructure as a service software as
a service platform as a service now the
difference is here it offers through
public private and hybrid cloud delivery
models vmware on the other hand is an
subsidiary of dell technologies and
provides cloud computing and platform
virtualization software and services it
was the first commercially successful
company to virtualize the x86
architecture google cloud platform on
the other hand is offered by google it's
a suit of cloud computing services that
run on the same infrastructure that
google uses internally for its end user
products such as the google search and
the youtube you're familiar with
alongside a set of managed tools it also
provides cloud services including
computing services data storage services
data analytics and machine learning
services digitalocean on the other hand
is headquartered in new york city with
data centers worldwide digitalocean
provides developers cloud services that
help to deploy and scale applications
that run simultaneously on multiple
computers as of january 2018
digitalocean was the third largest
hosting company in the world in terms of
web phasing computers let's talk about
cloud computing in aws amazon web
services aws is an cloud computing
service provided by amazon and these
services are accessible over the
internet and because aws provides
infrastructure as a service it's a
flagship offering we can create and
deploy any type of application in the
cloud on top of the is that amazon
provides and you know the best part here
is the subscriptions are pay as you go
type you use less and pay less and only
for what you have used you use more pay
more but still less per unit for the
service used attractive isn't it now
let's talk about the life cycle of the
cloud computing solution the very first
thing in the life cycle of a solution or
a cloud solution is to get a proper
understanding of the requirement i
didn't say get the requirement but said
get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
servers that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound understanding
of the requirement helps in picking the
right hardware one size does not fit all
there are different services and
hardwares for different needs you might
have like ec2 if you're looking for is
and lambda if you're looking for
serverless computing and ecs that
provides containerized service so there
are a lot of hardware's available pick
the right hardware that suits your
requirement the third thing is to define
the storage choose the appropriate
storage service where you can backup
your data and a separate storage service
where you can archive your data locally
within the cloud or from the internet
and choose the appropriate storage there
is one separately for backup called s3
and there is one separately for archival
that's for glacier so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
define the network define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications define and identify the
network services properly for example
vpc for network route 53 for dns and
direct connection for private p2p line
from your office to the aws data center
set up the right security services im
for authentication and authorization and
kms for data encryption at rest so there
are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are a
variety of deployment and automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example cloud watch is for
monitoring auto scaling is for being
elastic and cloud formation is define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your aws resources
and or the custom applications running
on aws platform there are variety of
deployment automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like cloud watch
for monitoring auto scaling for
automation and the cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build test and
deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done click
the analytic service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
services where we can start querying the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick athena
and other tools for analytics are emr
and which is elastic mapreduce and cloud
search all right enough of theory and
let's have a quick look at how two
services in aws ec2 and s3 work together
and benefits us here are two id
professionals talking to each other one
says i have an application which takes a
lot of storage and works only on linux
system which i do not have at the moment
and the other one is a smart guy and he
immediately replies that he could use s3
to store data and the tribe data and use
ec2 for all his compute needs and then
the curious conversation builds up and
the first person wants to know what is
easy to ns3 and the second guy starts to
explain that aws ec2 is a web service
that provides a secure and resizable
compute capacity in the cloud and ec2 it
can also be used to launch
as many virtual servers as we need and
about s3 he explains aws s3 is a simple
storage service provided by aws and
about s3 he explains further saying that
using amazon s3 we can store android
drive any amount of data at any time on
the web all right so the very first
thing is to have an aws account so
create an aws account and second thing
is to create an aws s3 bucket and upload
the files there you know the files that
ec2 server is going to pull from will
get stored in s3 as first thing all
right so the first thing is to create an
s3 bucket so let's create an s3 bucket
and let's call it as a website bucket
and these names will have to be unique
so let's see if this bucket name is
available it says bucket name already
taken or already exist so let me top it
up with sl meaning simply learn all
right so we were able to create a bucket
and in that bucket let me upload a
content that basically is going to be my
index file that's going to go and sit in
my web server so let me also make it
public and view it all right so this is
the content that i have stored in my s3
and this is the content i'm going to
push to my ec2 server right second step
create an aws s3 bucket and upload files
we're done with that third is to create
an ec2 instance that's in other words
create an virtual machine in the cloud
let's go and create it all right the
third thing is to create an ec2 instance
so let's create an ec2 instance it's
plain and it's very simple i'm going to
keep everything as defaults here all
right so i've launched an ec2 instance
as you see it's running i also have an
ip address public ip address here with
that i have logged into this ec2
instance and i'm in the folder slash war
slash www.html
and as you see there is nothing in there
at the moment and this server also has
apache installed in it as you can see
you know i browse to the ip address of
the ec2 instance and it's showing a page
which is the default apache page all
right if i had any files in this folder
that would get shown as the web page
insert off the default page our task is
to save files in s3 and move them to the
ec2 instance so s3 is going to act as a
storage or a repository or a source code
control in this example all right so
let's do that all right the third step
is to create your ec2 instance and
that's what we have done and the ec2
instance has no files in it and the
fourth step is to synchronize the source
code bucket with the ec2 instance let's
do that the actual command to do that
would be aws s3 sync and then the name
of the bucket from which we're going to
pull the code and the folder in which
we're going to put the code or the data
all right so it has downloaded something
look at that and now if we go back to
the test page and do a refresh there you
go it's showing the page that it pulled
from s3 so here i can use s3 as the
source code control bucket and
any information that i put in there will
get reflected in ec2 instance once i do
a sync every day and that's how i use s3
as my storage for ec2 alright finally we
were able to synchronize s3 bucket and
the ec2 instance let me start the
session with this scenario let's imagine
how life would have been without spotify
for those who are hearing about spotify
for the first time spotify is an online
music service offering and it offers
instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs spotify now uses aws
cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to aws
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before aws let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users cancelling the
subscription the problem spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and
they had different latency in their
applications and spotify had a demanding
situation where they need to frequently
catalog the songs released yesterday
today and in the future and this was
changing every new day and the songs
coming in rate was about 20 000 a day
and back then they could not keep up
with this requirement and needless to
say they were badly looking for a way to
solve this problem and that's when they
got introduced to aws and it was a
perfect fit and match for their problem
aws offered at dynamically increasing
storage and that's what they needed aws
also offered tools and techniques like
storage lifecycle management and trusted
advisor to properly utilize the resource
so we always get the best out of the
resource used aws addressed their
concerns about easily being able to
scale yes you can scale the aws
environment very easily how easily one
might ask it's just a few button clicks
and aws solved spotify's problem let's
talk about how it can help you with your
organization's problem let's talk about
what is aws first and then let's bleed
into how aws became so successful and
the different types of services that aws
provides and what's the future of cloud
and aws in specific let's talk about
that and finally we'll talk about a use
case where you will see how easy it is
to create a web application with aws all
right let's talk about what is aws aws
or amazon web services is a secure cloud
service platform it is also pay as you
go type billing model where there is no
upfront or capital cost we'll talk about
how soon the service will be available
well the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their idea
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they're almost
using all the services in aws and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database service and amazon s3
or amazon's simple storage servers
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about 5
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
servers because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift ft is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric ge is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
erp systems to aws while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly howard
medical school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws
beat a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a beaten java.net php nodejs
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon light sale
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
lightsail is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing service lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon s3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and deter any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility and managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on premises an amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon reshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
analyze all your data using standard sql
and your existing business intelligent
tools it also allows you to run complex
analytic queries against petabyte of
structured data using sophisticated
query optimizations and most of the
results they generally come back in
seconds all right let's quickly talk
about some more services that aws offers
there are a lot more services that aws
provides but we're going to look at some
more services that are widely used aws
application discovery services help
enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on-premises data centers and a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
are important early first step in
migration process and this aws
application discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable cloud domain name
system or dns service and amazon route
53 is fully compliant with ipv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as amazon
ec2 instance containers and ip addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones adobe's auto scaling
it monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using
iam you can create and manage aws users
and groups and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to aws resources
and moreover it's a free service now
let's talk about the future of aws well
let me tell you something cloud is here
to stay here's what in store for aws in
the future as years pass by we're going
to have a variety of cloud applications
bond like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as i was mentioning some time
back lot our greater focus will be given
to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy and web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because aws has tools and technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like route
53 services like cloudwatch ec2 s3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use route 53 for dns and route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so i'm going
to use elastic beanstalk for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see gsg sign up
and the environment name is gsg sign up
environment one let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that i have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance it's going
to launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if i
go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with name samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right and
some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind and load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's it's not a fancy url right
it's an amazon given url a dynamic url
so let's put this url behind our dns
let's do that
so go to services go to route53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the
dns name right so that's a dns name all
right
all right let's create an entry
and map that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url and let me help you understand about
aws ec2 a compute servers in the cloud
through this video somewhere far in the
country a scientist has a lab far in the
woods and at one day he stumbled on a
calculation that he had trouble solving
and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it and he asked his
computer to do the math or the
calculation for him and the computer
thought about it for a while then took a
couple of hours in trying to process the
data and eventually at one point it gave
up and died due to low memory and this
old scientist is now clueless about how
he was going to finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend aws as
you see on the screen aws was very handy
in replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment aws has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend in need is welcomed by
the new and trendy id technology aws and
sure enough his new aws friend welcomed
and walked him through the new way of
computing and this new happy-faced aws
friend talked to this scientist about
aws ec2 in specific and walked him
through about all the new innovations in
i.t and in cloud that he had been
missing all these days so his new friend
aws started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing hardware or
provisioning in aws and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there's no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with enterprise great security that's
beyond imagination in on premises and if
this still does not excite you then this
definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world
now this really made the scientist to
get excited especially when he thought
about working from home working from
home there is nothing like it isn't it
now this person the scientist is not
tied up to a particular environment he
can work from home work on the fly work
from anywhere still the data and
everything else in his id environment is
secure and safe now let's move to the
next level of discussion let's talk
about what is ec2 and some of the use
cases of ec2 and this use case we're
going to talk about are this
architecture we're going to talk about
it notifies a group of users about a new
letter and the components are resources
this architecture would need the first
ec2 instance then sns a simple
notification service and
coupling ec2 and s3 service together
that's all it would require to get an
architecture that notifies a group of
users about a new newsletter and now i
think it would be a good time to talk
about what ec2 is aws offers plenty of
services offered under different domains
like you know compute storage database
migration network management tools media
services security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for developers for providing secure and
resetable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by aws in aws
we can use services like simple
notification service sns and ec2 for
compute and s3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve this
business use case and that sort of got
this business owner very cheered up and
now he wants to use the service and he
wants to get benefited from the service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users every time the company
creates a newsletter all right so let's
talk about what it would take to get
this environment up and running or what
it would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an aws account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an ami which is amazon mission
image that's really the
and the application packages we would
need to run our application and the
second is to choose the hardware in here
it's the instance type depending on the
workload we would be choosing the
hardware and depending on the intents of
the workload we will be choosing the
size of the hardware and finally we
would configure the instances and how
many instances do i want you know which
subnet do i want them in and what's
going to be the in a stop or terminate
behavior of the instance and do i want
to update any patches when the instance
starts running all those pieces of
information go in here when we configure
the instance
and then the first three steps is really
about the os volume and the basic
hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called security group for
the ec2 instance and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and ip address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
summit that's going to launch an ec2
instance all right this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an ami
well the ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an new computer or a new vm
or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the ami
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined amis are called amazon
provided amis the other one would be
custom amis the amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from amazon there is a
place or a portal called ami marketplace
there we get like thousands of amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
or lots of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power i should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in-memory caching you know there
are some application that performs well
with cache or through cache or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cache for
rereading or for processing you know for
lengthy processing stuff like that for
those type of application this memory
optimized instance that comes with in
memory cache is a very good use case and
the third one is the instant that comes
with the gpu otherwise called gpu
optimized gpu stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimize is the
fourth option just like the name says
this is a very good use case for storage
servers and the fifth family type is
general purpose just like the name says
it's for general purpose if you're not
particular about the family then you
generally would end up picking the
general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual cpu and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's hardware based we buy hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
compute optimized memory optimized gpu
enabled storage optimized and general
purpose then as third thing we have to
configure the instance now here is where
i have a lot of options about
purchasing you know what type of
purchasing do i want to do do i want to
go for a spot instance do i want to go
for a reserved instance do i want to go
for an on-demand instance these are
different billing options available and
that's available under configure
instance not only that here's where i'm
going to put the ec2 instance do i want
and public ipads assigned to it do i
want an im role attached to it im role
is authentication what kind of
authentication am i going to provide and
the shutdown behavior the shutdown
behaviors include do i want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do i want to
simply terminate the instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or advanced tab under configure instance
i can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per r for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand instances and through bidding
and buying you can keep the instance as
long as your bid price doesn't exceed
the price that amazon is proposing and
as the fourth step we will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have bunch
of storage options i can go for a
permeable storage which is free or i can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called ebs which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else i can
integrate my ec2 instance with s3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is free subscription users
they get to use 30 gigabit of ssd
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be
and
provisioned volume is it going to be and
general purpose volume is it going to be
a magnetic volume stuff like that they
are volume types and we also need to
give inputs about where the disc will be
mounted and whether this volume needs to
be encrypted or not so all these options
are all these inputs are received from
us under the adding storage section and
then the fifth option would be adding
tags like we discussed some time back
tags are very helpful to identify a
machine in an environment where we have
700 or 1000 vms running and security
groups are the actual firewall that sits
in front of ec2 instance and it protects
that ec2 instance from unintended
inbound and outbound traffic now here is
where i can fine tune the access to my
ec2 instance based on port numbers and
based on ip address from which it can be
accessed and finally we get to review
the whole changes or the whole
configurations that we have made to find
out whether they are intact with the
requirement and then click on submit
that's going to launch an ec2 instance
but hold on we're not done yet when
we're about to launch or before the
amazon console actually launches the ec2
instance it's going to give us an option
to create a keypad remember i said it's
key pair you know key pair is two things
one is public and private the private
key is downloaded by the user and is
kept with the user and the public key is
used by amazon to confirm the identity
of the user so just go ahead and
download the private key and keep it for
yourself and this private key gets
downloaded as a dot pem file it's a
format of the file and it gets
downloaded as dot pem file and our next
step is to access the ec2 instance and
because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's linux instance and that's going to
require a tool called putty to be able
to access it and this putty tool is
really needed when we are trying to
access and linux instance from windows
instance most of the time windows
instance will have putty installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and put the
generator and we can start using it to
access the linux instance now you might
ask well i understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called ppk and puttygen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into ppk file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pen key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a dot ppk
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open puti and
try to log in and the way to log in is
to open putty put that ip address here
and then click on auth
you know this is where we would input
the file that we have created so click
on auth and then click on browse and
find the dot ppk file that we have
converted and stored browse it and
upload it and then click on open now
that's going to open up a login screen
for us and the amis comes with a default
username depending on the ami that we
have picked the username might differ in
our case we have picked an ami for which
the username is ec2 hyphen user and this
is the default by the way let's put the
username ec2hyphen user and hit enter
and that's going to open up the linux
instance using cli there are a few other
things that we can do with the terminal
that we'll explain it little later all
right so we have successfully launched
an ec2 instance and
yeah give yourself a pat on your back
launching an instance was just one part
of the solution so let's actually talk
about how we can notify our customers
sns or simple notification service is a
service or a product in amazon that
helps us to notify customers through
email so navigate to sns in your account
and create a topic and we're going to
use this topic for public notification
so let's make it public and then add
subscribers to it now these subscribers
these subscribers are the people who you
want to be notified about the newsletter
so we already have the email database in
there add them to the subscribers list
and then they will start getting new
newsletters as and when we post them to
the topic and as next step create a
bucket in s3 where you can store content
and in that bucket create an event that
triggers a notification to simple
notification service so this is how it
will be set up and notification will be
sent to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our s3 bucket so s3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the s3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
aws instance are in sync so we put some
content in the s3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because s3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
s3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the s3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website let me welcome you
to this new video learning where we're
going to learn about lambda and i'm very
glad that you're watching this aws
lambda tutorial now one day at office in
a growing company there was discussion
going on between two it personal it was
about the new role that his colleague
jessica has taken benjamin the guy
standing here wants to know about it and
jessica's job is new different and
dynamic and interesting too she scale
and manage servers and operating systems
and apply security patches onto them and
monitor all of these at the same time to
ensure the best quality for application
is given to the users and benjamin was
awestruck with the amount of work
jessica is doing and with the time it
would take to complete all of them but
jessica being a very dynamic person very
suitable for the job said it was easy
for her to handle all of it and even
more but that easiness on the job did
not last longer as the environment grew
more and more it being a startup company
jessica was getting drained and was not
really happy about all her job as she
used to be jessica's manual way of
scaling and environment did not last
long and she was also finding out that
she missed to scale down some of the
resources and it's costing her a lot she
needs to pay for the service that she
was not at all using she sort of felt
that she was at the end of the road and
there was no way out from this manual
task she was very desperate and that's
when benjamin suggested something and
that brought back the peace and joy
jessica initially had benjamin suggested
about a service called lambda that can
ease the work that jessica is doing at
the moment and lambda as happy as it
looks like it's a solution that solves
the manual repetitive work and lot more
and lambda introduced itself as the
problem solver and started to explain
the following things the very same thing
that we're gonna learn about in this
series so in this section we're gonna
learn about the features of aws lambda
and we're gonna talk about what lambda
is and then we're going to talk about
where lambda is being used in the it or
in the cloud environment as we speak and
then we're going to talk about how
lambda works and some use cases of
lambda and we're going to be
particularly discussing about the use
case about automatically backing up the
data that's put in the cloud storage
let's talk about lambda in detail lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to lambda and lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to lambda and lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working aws lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in lambda is metered
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with aws lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
aws lambda now lambda is one of the
servers that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that aws provides along with
ec2 ebs elastic load balancer lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
aws and lambda allows us to execute code
or any type of application with aws
lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that aws lambda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by aws lambda are node.js
java c-sharp go and python and lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c sharp etc now let's talk about
where is lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for lambda and there
are many ways aws lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
aws lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an s3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
s3 bucket in a format that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and aws lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that would be reading the data it
could be an pc it could be an apple
machine it could be an android phone it
could be an apple phone it could be a
tablet what not so based on the devices
different formats lambda can get
triggered and convert the video or
convert the picture into the different
format that it requires another use case
for lambda is to analyze the social
media data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's uh added
into the kinesis stream to feed into the
amazon environment and lambda action get
triggered and it receives the data and
then the data is stored into the
database which can be used by
businesses for later analysis and some
of the companies that have gotten
tremendous benefit using lambda or
thomson routers bench links
not storm coca-cola robot are some of
the companies to name at the moment that
have received tremendous amount of
benefit by using lambda let's look at
how lambda works in other words let's
look at how the complicated function
behind the scenes work in a simple and
in a seamless way so here clients send
data now clients send data to lambda and
clients could be anyone who's sending
requests to aws lambda it could be an
application or other amazon web services
that's sending data to the lambda and
lambda receives the request and
depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any other settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running a
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
lambda so if there are a few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we're only charged for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and
as a system to backup the data as soon
as the data is uploaded which is a near
real time backup now a near real time
manual backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too and near
real time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that to a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real time
that's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and keep it as real as possible
but if that's still your requirement we
can use aws lambda and set things up so
aws lambda manually handles the backup
in other words for an impossible or a
difficult situation like that aws lambda
comes for the rescue and this is what we
do create a 2s3 bucket one would be the
source bucket where the data will be
uploaded and the other one is and
destination bucket where the data will
be backed up from the source bucket and
for these buckets to talk to themselves
it's going to require an im role and
then for the automatic copy it's going
to require an lambda function to copy
the files from the source bucket to the
destination bucket and what triggers the
lambda function the lambda function is
triggered every time there's a change in
the metadata for the bucket and this
data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from the source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
buckets well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in s3 that's a feature
that comes along with s3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here would be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an iem role
that lets you access to pull data from
the source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
lambda files or lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
lambda gets triggered copies the data
from the source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the iam role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible
right that's the concept and let's see
how it is done real time through this
lab so to begin with we need two buckets
so i have here a source bucket and a
destination bucket and the source bucket
as of now do not have any data in it so
as the destination bucket all right so
that's one down the second would be to
create an im role right so let me create
an im role and the role is going to have
this policy in it a policy that's
allowing get object on the source bucket
and a policy that's allowing put object
on the destination bucket and here i'm
going to use or i'm going to paste my
source and destination buckets arn all
right go to services go to s3
source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket drn
so that would be the source bucket arn
all right on on the destination bucket
copy the destination bucket arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket arn so with this i'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to im
and create a policy
now i i have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket arn and a policy is
available with the name s3 bucket copy
lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to roles create a role lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it a name
and then create a role now i have a role
created as well
right copy lambda and that's having the
policy that we have created sometime
back now create a lambda function right
so go to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right choose the role
that we want to use
all right that's the row that we want to
use copy one two
create a function
all right
and in here
we're gonna use node.js code right i
have a sample code
this can be used as template here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggered now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the s3 bucket it
creates an event and the even triggers
lambda and lambda checks the source s3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here
and click on save right now before you
click on save just ensure that you have
the appropriate roles defined that's all
you got to do click on save all right
now i i already have created
a lambda function
right
which is the same thing same code and
the rule is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to
s3 pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and
in theory those data should be present
in the destination bucket as well
there you go it's all done by lambda and
i'm going to be touring you with
different s3 features and technical
details in this section so what are we
going to learn we're going to learn
about what is cloud storage in general
and then the types of storage available
in general in the cloud and how things
were before anybody adopted using s3
that's something we're going to learn
and then we're going to immediately dive
into what is s3 and then the benefits of
using s3 over other storage and then
we're going to do a couple of
labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how amazon s3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of promise um how does this
all work how does amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with the amazon s3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that the data can be easily accessed and
the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in short if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could back your
your data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and the additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use you know no
commitment no pre-provisioning is you
know pay-as-you-go type subscription and
the best part is we pay on a monthly
basis you know we don't rent a hardware
for the year or we don't give commitment
for the whole year it's pay as you go
and pay on a monthly basis and these
cloud storages are very reliable meaning
once you put the data in it it's never
going to get lost and these cloud
storages are scalable assuming i have a
requirement to store 100 times of what
my actual data sizes and i want it now
it's available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data data virginity
they need to be secure and amazon
provides tools and technologies through
which we can secure our data and these
are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so s3 is a cloud storage in aws
and then we have a elastic block store
now elastic block store is actually the
ssd hard drives that gets attached to
our ec2 instance you know it's like the
c drive it's like the d drive it's like
the e drive that gets attached to our
instances now efs is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from ebs in a way
that ebs can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the d volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
efs are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right they're
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the amazon environment it
can be accessed from on-premises
equipment as well a glacier is actually
the archiving solution in the cloud if
you want to dump a data
and try to keep them in
the low cost as possible then glacier is
the product we should be using and then
we have storage gateway if i want to
safely move my data from my local
environment to the cloud environment and
also want to keep a copy of the data
locally so users locally can access them
and in a cloud users or internet users
can access the data from the cloud if
that's your requirement then storage
gateway is the one we would be choosing
and then we have snowball snowball is
really an
data import and export system but
it is actually an hardware that gets
shipped to our premises where we can
copy our data into it and then ship it
back to amazon and amazon would copy the
data into whatever destination we give
them in our account and if the data is
really huge then i can call for a
snowmobile which is actually a data
center on a truck where amazon would
send me and truck loaded with the data
center as you see that has compute
capacity lots and lots of storage
capacity and electricity uh ac and lot
more so they get come parked near our
data center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it send it
back to amazon and they would copy it to
our account in whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is really
really huge then i would be calling
snowmobile snowmobile is not available
in all the regions all right let's take
this example how things were before s3
was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
company grow and we are living in an era
where data is everything we want data to
back up every idea we want data to back
up every proof of concept that we
provide so data is everything so in this
era it's all about uh collecting data
analyzing them and saving you know not
losing logs you know saving them
analyzing stuff like that so coming back
to our discussion here one person finds
it very difficult to store and manage
all the data that they have so some of
the data that this person is having
problem storing is data's that
application use to running and then data
that gets sent to the customers and
data's that the websites require the
data that are because of the email
backups and a lot more other storages
that an enterprise can have and this
person is having problem backing up all
those data and even if we think of
increasing the local storage capacity
that's going to cost the fortune and few
things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity in-house is
you know we will have to go and pay
heavy to buy hardware and software to
run these storages and we need to hire a
team of experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to s3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to estee
in other words all the scalability all
the
data security all the not being able to
provision hardware and software
components are all available with s3 so
that actually brings us to the
discussion about what s3 is s3 is simple
storage service it actually provides an
object storage service let me talk to
you about object and block storage
object storage is where you can store
things into drive all right you can't
install anything in it and this object
storage can be accessed directly from
the internet whereas block storage is
something that needs to be attached to
an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's a high
level difference between object storage
and block storage and s3 is an object
storage what does that mean we can store
data from the internet we can retry from
the internet but uh we can't install
anything in s3 all right so so s3 is an
object based storage and it's it's
really built for storing and recovering
or driving any amount of data or
information from anywhere in the
internet few other things you need to
know about s3 is that the s3 is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing s3 is by dragging dropping
content into it and another way of
retrieving data from s3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be 5 terabytes in size now
we're talking about one file you know
you can have hundreds or thousands of
files like that one file can be as big
as five terabytes in size and s3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into s3 or drive logs
anytime they want instead of storing
locally in the server they can use s3 as
code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are a few things about s3 and on
top of all these s3 provides 11 9
durability and four nine availability
meaning durability is if i store the
data will it get lost amazon is like no
it's not gonna get lost you're gonna
have the data because we provide 11 9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it we have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of s3 s3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability s3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
amazon s3 is the cheapest and s3 is very
scalable like we were saying that
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you will be paying less
so it's very scalable in nature and it's
very available as well s3 isn't regional
service you know it's not based on one
availability zone so one availability
zone going down within amazon the whole
availability going down it's not going
to affect your ability to access s3
storage ns3 is secure a lot of security
features like bucket policy a lot of
security features like encryption and
then mfa authentication are possible
with s3 that actually adds a very good
security layer on top of the data that
we have stored in s3 and not only that
this s3 is very flexible in terms of
cost flexible in terms of where i want
to store the data in terms of cost there
are a lot of pricing tiers within s3 uh
s3 itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of price and tiers
depending on the durability so i can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in the region i can always choose any of
the region available in the console or
in the s3 console to put my data to
there is no restrictions on where i can
or cannot put the data in the cloud as
long as there are regions available for
me to move the data to and data
transferring with s3 is very simple all
i have to do is browse to the bucket
upload the data and the data gets
uploaded and we can also upload data
using cli commands are very similar to
linux commands are very similar to what
we would use in the run command prompt
in windows and what we would use in the
run command prompt
in the powershell all right let's talk
about
a basic building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data and bucket is the folder where the
objects get stored let me give you a new
definition for objects so object is the
actual data plus some information that
reference the data like is it a jpeg
file the name of the file and at what
time it was added to so they're called
metadata all right so object is actually
data plus metadata and bucket is
actually a container that receives the
data and safely stores in it and when we
add a data in a bucket amazon s3 creates
an unique version id and allocates it to
the object so we can easily identify it
at a later point let me show you a quick
lab on s3
all right i'm in the s3 console if
you're wondering how i reached here
go to services under storage and s3 is
right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so i really doubt if simply learn
will be available let's
let's check it anyway
all right it's doesn't seem to be
available so
um
let me pick another name or let's call
it simplylearn.samuel.com
and i'm going to put this in
mumbai or i can choose oregon
let me choose oregon
oregon
yes
let me choose oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and
you know these objects can be as big as
5 terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right
here is a bucket
right here is my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file
plus what type of file it is
and then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added and the storage
class it is in at the moment
so if i have to access it
i can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this s3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions amazon provides s3
service you know beat not virginia beat
mumbai beat tokyo beat sydney beat
argonne and we chose argonne to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case we picked the
default which was uh s3 standard as we
saw on the object data it was on s3
standard so that's the basic thing later
once the object gets added we can always
add
bucket policies you know policies define
who access it and who should not access
it what can they access are we going to
allow users only to read or to read
write as well stuff like that so that's
bucket policy we're defining the life
cycle or the life span of the data in
the s3 bucket now over the time do you
want the data to automatically move to a
different storage tier and at any point
do you want to sort of expire the data
you know get the data flushed out of
your account automatically and those
things can be configured in lifecycle
policies and version control is creating
multiple versions if you're going to use
s3 for a code repository creating
multiple versions let's say if you want
to roll back to whatever you had before
a month how are you going to do it if
you kept updating the file and never
took a version of it so version control
helps us to keep different versions and
it helps us to roll back to the older
version anytime there is a need so let's
talk about the different storage classes
in s3 the different storage classes in
s3 begins with s3 standard now this is
the default and it's very suitable for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example if you want to
access the data of students attendance
you would retrieve them very quickly as
much as possible so that's a good use
case to store data in s3 let's
understand the different storage classes
in amazon s3 now let's take
a school for example
and
the the different data is present in a
school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example and uh there are
different storage options in s3 let's
take s3 standard for example and what
would be the actual candidate data that
can be stored in s3 standard let's talk
about that so s3 standard in general is
suitable for use cases where the latency
should be very low and in here the good
example or the good candidate file that
can be stored in s3 is a data that
needs to be frequently accessed and that
needs to be retrieved quickly something
like students attendance
report or students attendance sheet
which we access daily and then it needs
to be retrieved immediately as and when
we need it the other type of storage
chair in s3 is infrequent access or
infrequent data access just like the
name says the use case for that is less
frequently accessed data i mean the
candidate data that should go in
infrequent access data is a student's
academic record you know which we don't
need to access on a daily basis but if
there is a requirement we might want to
go and look at it and that's going to be
quick so it's not a data that we would
access on a daily basis but it's data
that needs to show up on your screen
real quick and the third option is
amazon glacier now glacier is really an
archival solution in the cloud so for
archives high performance is not a
requirement so let's talk about some
candidate data that can go into archives
something like students admission fee
and it's not critical also now anytime
if you want to look at the data you can
always wait to retrieve the data so in
other words you know put it in the
archive and the driving from the
archival takes time so students old
record are a good candidate to be put in
the archives the other options are one
zone ia storage class where the data is
in frequently accessed and the data is
stored in a single availability zone for
example now by default amazon stores
data in multiple availability zones and
uh there is a charge for that now it's
not an option but the charge includes
storing data in multiple availability
zones but if your data requirement is
you want to keep the charges in a low
even further you can choose a one zone
ia storage class where it stores data in
one availability zone and the candidate
data that can go in one zone in frequent
access is students report card and the
other option with amazon s3 is standard
reduced redundancy storage it is
suitable for cases where the data is not
critical and the data can be reproduced
quickly for example you know take
a copy of the library book take a copy
of the pdf library book for example now
we would have a source pdf and we would
make copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in s3 is reduced redundancy
storage here the use case is data that's
not critical and the data can be
reproduced quickly welcome to this new
learning
series called i am a service in aws for
security here in this section we're
going to talk about what is security in
aws and then we're going to slowly or
gradually move on to the other topics
like types of security available in aws
out of all the services why i am is the
most preferred one and then we're going
to talk about what is im in general how
it works the building blocks or
components in im and the features it the
the attractive features that it provides
that makes iam stand out from the rest
of the services available we're going to
talk about that and then we're going to
end today's session with a demo about
how iam gets well interacted with the
other services in amazon and help create
a secure environment in the cloud let's
talk about aws security now cloud
security is the highest priority in aws
and when we host our environment in the
cloud we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement of
the most security sensitive organization
and this high level of security is
available to us on a pay-as-you-go type
meaning there is really no upfront cost
that we need to pay and the cost for
using the service is lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment so aws cloud provides and a
secure virtual platform where we can
deploy our application now compared to
the on premises with aws the security
level is very high and the cost involved
in using or attaching that type of
security to our application is very low
compared to on premises there's really
no upfront cost and the cost is very
lower whatever cost that we pay is very
lower than what it would be in on
premises and all this contributes to the
secure environment we can get through im
in aws cloud there are really many types
of security services available in aws to
name a few are to name the familiar ones
im stands first followed by a key
management system kms and then we have
cognito that's another service and web
access firewall vaf is another security
service in aws now let's start our
discussion by talking about i am and
that's what this whole series is about
now i am or identity and access
management it really enables us to
manage access to aws services and
awareness resources in a very secure
manner with im we can create
groups we can actually allow those users
or groups to access some service or we
can sort of deny them to access the
servers whichever we want that's all
possible through identity and access
management and this feature comes with
no additional charge let's talk about
how things were before aws before aws or
before i am
in general it was not that safe in a
corporate to share the password over the
phone or through the email that was the
practice that was existed at that time
now we all can remember the days when we
need to switch to a different account or
we had just one admin password commonly
stored in a location or one person would
reset it and maintain it and anytime or
we need to log in we call the person
asks for the admin password over the
phone and then we try logging in now
that was not secure at all back then no
somebody could walk by and sort of
eavesdrop you know get the password now
they walk away with the password with
them so they're all possible when we
share the password over the phone and
through the internet or email now with
aws a lot of options are available that
i'm not sharing password over the
unsecure medium now a slack is a
third-party product available with aws
it's not an aws product but slack is in
party application that's hosted on aws
and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share documents so
now we're not sharing the password over
the phone rather through the
applications and no eavesdrop person can
really catch the password and you know
try it in their system to access our
environment that's not possible so you
see the difference now back then sharing
password was only through phone and
email and you would write it on a paper
and you give it to somebody but now
technology is providing provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way we're still talking about i
am im as an web service for securely
controlling access to the aws resource
now it really helps us to authenticate
or sort of limit access to a certain set
of users accessing the aws account or
certain set of users accessing a certain
set of resources in aws account now you
see this picture we have an im
administrator who is trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have group one on the top and
group two in the middle and group three
towards the end the administrator using
iam or iam empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what iam is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete im so the elements are
categorized into six
different elements we have the principle
in im the authentication the request the
actual request coming in the
authorization allowing denying access
actions what are the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy too is it rds is it s3 bucket so
what resource these actions are applied
to so they are the basic elements of an
iem workflow let's talk about principle
for example an action on aws resource
can only be performed by a principal an
individual user they can be a principal
a role in aws im it can be a principle
as well in other words a principal is an
entity that can take an action on an aws
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the aws environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity of the principle
trying to access the aws environment now
how do we get authenticated or how does
the user get authenticated by providing
credentials or the required keys to
validate that this is what he or she is
as per what's in the record so all
principle must be authenticated and we
get authenticated using the username and
password to log into the console if it
is cli or we get authenticated using the
access key and the secret access key
the other component that makes up im is
request when a principal tries to use
the aws management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is sending a request to the aws
environment and the request will have
the principal actually wants to perform
is it a put request or is it a get
request or is the delete request stuff
like that and it's also going to carry
information about on which resource the
action needs to be done is it on easy to
one is it on s3bucketsimplylearn.com
stuff like that so it has a specific
action that it wants to perform and the
resource on which it wants to perform
and also some information about from
where the request is originating from is
it within an aws environment or is it
with another cloud service provider or
is it with on-premises stuff like that
so these information will be present in
the request authorization now this iam
uses information from the request
context to check for matching policies
and it determines it takes a decision
whether to allow or to deny the request
now here it has a logic by default all
the resources are denied and im
authorizes your request only if every
part of the request is allowed by a
matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic that says by default
all requests are denied and if there is
an explicit allow
then it overrides the default deny and
if you are explicitly denying a service
then all the allow statements gets
overridden and all the other statements
gets overwritten and this explicit deny
stands by default only the aws account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy now
let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request aws approves the action that we
are about to take now using action we
can view the content we can create a
content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance i can edit content or even
i can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that i'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say if you
attempt to delete an im role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of im so the other
components are im are the basic building
block is an user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection
based on policy one gets to access or
gets no access to a resource and then
roles roles are another component rules
are temporary credentials i would say
that can get assumed to an instance as
in when needed let's talk about this
component called user in an im with im
we can securely manage access to aws
services and
we can create an im user anytime there
is a new employee joining our corporate
so it's a one-to-one mapping you know
one user or one employee get a username
directly attached to them and a username
or a user is an account specific thing
you know it's very local to that aws
account that we are using so for in
detail an imuser is an entity that
we create in an aws environment to
represent a person or a service that
interacts with aws environment and this
user is going to have some credentials
attached to them and by default they do
not have
a password and they do not have any
access key or secret access key attached
to them in fact literally no credentials
of any kind now we must create an user
and we must create the type of
credential that gets attached to the
user do they want to access a cli so
based on that we would be adding
credentials to them a user by default is
not authorized to perform any action in
aws and the advantage of having
one-to-one user is that
we can assign permissions individually
to that user for example we might want
to assign administrative permissions to
few users who can administer our aws
environment and users are entity within
an aws account users don't have to pay
separately you know they start using
their servers and that get bills under
the account they are attached to so
separate users doesn't mean that
separate payment for those users they
are just users in our account and
you know the whole account gets to pay
for the resources that they provision
again the im user does not always
represent a person an iem user is really
just an identity with associated
credential and permissions attached to
it it could be an actual person who is a
user and it could be an application also
a who is a user next we'll talk about
groups talking about groups or
understanding group is very easy a
collection of user forms an iem group
and we can use iam group to specify
permission for multiple users so that
any permission that's applied to the
group is also applied to the users who
are at add to that group now there are a
few things you might want to know about
group a group can have
many users and a user they can belong to
many groups but groups can't be nested
meaning group can only have users a
group cannot have a group inside a group
that's not possible and there's nothing
called a default group that sort of
automatically includes all users in the
aws account
if you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of an uh small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are
people users who are applications that
interact with aws environment so the
different types of users we have are
jim is a user brad is an user and dev
app one is a user and and so on so each
users have an individual set of security
credential like i said it's one to one
and the uh
10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy uh if i add another
user to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with im all right
the next thing we will want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to aws resource and
the policies this permissions and
controls are stored in json format a
policy is a very clear document it
defines who has access to a resource and
what are all the actions they can
perform so in other words policy is an
entity in aws that when a policy gets
attached to an identity or a resource
you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and aws it evaluates these policies when
a principal such as a user makes a
request and the permission statement in
the policy it really defines whether the
user is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this example now we
have a task the task is to give paul
who's a developer access to amazon s3
environment and what you're looking at
is a snippet of what a policy would look
like so these are some questions we will
have to answer or these are some
questions the policy tries to answer and
once it found an answer then it becomes
a complete policy so who wants access to
the service it's paul who wants access
to the service and what action do paul
want now paul wants to
download or paul wants to upload objects
in s3 in json language it's otherwise
called paul wants to get information
paul wants to put information otherwise
paul wants to get object paul wants to
put object in s3 and which resource does
he want now in this case every bucket
the star symbol represents all buckets
in history so which resource it's all
bucket in s3 so we can stop reading
already from the data present here so
who wants access paul wants access what
action does he want he wants to get he
wants to put and what's the resource
that he's trying to access or you want
to give him access it's all the bucket
in aws and when does he want these
additional statement that goes in a
policy so since when does he want that
access he wants access till march 2nd
2019 so all this who all this action all
this resource you know till the time all
this gets allowed so this is the
statement that really defines now does
this all refer to an allow statement or
does this all refer to a deny statement
if we had deny here it's the direct
opposite of what we discussed but we
have allow that means paul is allowed to
get and put access in an s3 bucket and
all the buckets in s3 till march 2nd
2019 he's allowed to access the
resources so if we put together put all
the information that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in a json format this is
how it's going to look like so
the effect is
allow or deny here it's allowing and the
principal uh is any now who can access
it it's any and action it's any bucket
in s3 any action in s3 put get request
and the resource is any bucket in s3 so
that's how a basic policy would look
like or that's how a basic policy is
formed by answering those basic
questions so let's talk about the types
of policies so we have two broad
categories managed policy and inline
policy the manage policy it's the
default policy that we attach to
multiple entries be users be groups and
beat roles in our aws account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are embedded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
i need to brief
it a little bit more then a managed
policies are standalone identity based
policies that we can attach to multiple
users groups and roles in our aws
account we can use two types of managed
policies in other words manage policies
they themselves have two categories one
is aws managed policies which is created
and managed by aws and the other one is
customer manage policies just like the
name says it's managed by the customer
now we can create and edit an im policy
in visual editor or simply create a json
policy document directly and upload it
in the console and start using them so
that's manage policy on the other hand
inline policies are policies that we
create and manage and that are embedded
directly into a single user group or
role let's talk about this next
component called role now this role is
very similar to everything that we
discussed so far uh it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an aws console the role is
very similar to an user i said very
similar i didn't say it's the same as
the user but i said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard-coded user permissions are hard
coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity you know beta
user or a beat and aws service and
moreover the role permissions are
temporary on the other hand user
permissions are permanent and the role
permissions are temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an aws entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in aws
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it roles generally do not have an
long term credential you know password
or access keys associated with it you
know it does not have
long term credentials it only has
temporary credentials created
dynamically and provided to the user as
in when the user assumes a role and
wants to access any service roles can be
assumed by users roles can be assumed by
applications roles can be assumed by
services that normally you don't have
access to aws resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your aws
account access to your resource that
they do not
normally have or grant users in one aws
account access to resource in another
aws account now this is something that
we don't have by default and this is
something we may not need all the time
or you might want to allow a mobile app
to use aws resource but you do not want
to save the key or save the credential
or save the passwords in the mobile app
or sometimes you might want to give
access to resources who already have
identities defined outside of aws like a
user who's already and google or
facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our aws resources
remember they are not permanent users
just templar users they want some
temporary access to our environmental
the audit is over so for those cases
roles are a very good use case so let's
take this
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles give permission to
other services so here is a scenario
where where an ec2 instance
wants access to an s3 bucket by default
though both of them were created by the
same username or the same admin they do
not have access by default so by default
they don't have access and i also do not
want to give permanent access you know
one-on-one hard-coded permanent access
instead i would like to create and share
access so that's possible to roll so
coming back to the discussion uh the
scenario here is that an ac2 instance
wants to access data in an s3 bucket so
the first thing is to create a role or a
permission we saw how that's done right
using policies roles use policies policy
is the actual working engine for any
permission related actions right so
create a role with an appropriate policy
that gives access to s3's bucket and
then launch an ec2 instance with the
role attached to it we said rules are
assumed by any entity right it could be
user it could be an application it could
be a service it could be another
resource in aws account so here it's
another resource in aws account right so
we create a role and we attach it to an
ec2 instance so now the ec2 instance can
assume the role now the same role can be
attached to another ec2 instance the
same rule can be attached to
another user the same rule can be
attached to another database service we
get the idea right roles can be assumed
by anyone so when the ec2 instance wants
to communicate with s3 it contacts the
role and then the role gives this ec2
instance some temporary username and
password that expires after one hour
let's say so it's a temporary username
and password now with that temporary
username and password the ec2 instance
can access the
s3 bucket and access the file with the
credential that it already has and that
credential is a temporary one and the
credential will expire after one hour or
how much ever time the admin sets it to
be and then the next time when when an
ec2 instance wants to contact s3 it will
have to contact the role and the role
will propose a new access key and secret
access key in other words a new
credential with that new credential the
second time the ec2 instance will be
able to contact the s3 bucket and get
the information so the password is not a
permanent or a one-time or a hard-coded
password it keeps rotating it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the role
gets to access the resources on the
other end well let's talk about the
features of im the main feature of iam
is that i can create separate username
and password for individual users or
resources and i can delegate access no
those days where we had just one
username and password for admin and we
need to call the other person to get the
username and password over the phone uh
if it gets compromised you know the
whole account gets compromised stuff
like that those issues are gone i can
create separate username and password
for all thousand users in my account no
more username and password sharing i can
manage access to all those thousand
accounts in a very simple and an easy
way so im provides shared access for all
the thousand users in my account it
provides share access to the aws
environment and the permissions that can
be given through im are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get requests you know we can allow a
user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the iem policies that we looked
at sometime back and with the use of
roles you know we are authenticating an
ec2 instance instead of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 applications running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances i
can create a role and assign that role
to the
ec2 instance and all the applications
running on the ec2 instance get a secure
access to the other resources use the
role credential that's provided to that
ec2 instance now besides username and
password im also supports multi-factor
authentication where we provide our
credential the username and password
plus an otp from our phone or an
randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before amazon console or before amazon
cli would authenticate and
lets us
access some of the servers in the
account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's username and
password plus something else from what
you have im also provides identity
federation if a user is already
authenticated with a corporate ad or
facebook or google you know im can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on-premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on-premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in a every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the uh
cloud username and password now with
identity federation we can sort of
federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on premises
and im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there is no additional charge for im
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account im is an pci dss
compliant product now im comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely and we can set rules
like how a user should pick an password
it should not be the one that was used
in the past any of the past three times
stuff like that so
you get the idea right how the features
of im help us to build and a secure
authentication and authorization system
in or for our aws account
all right it's time to do a quick lab
let's let's put all the knowledge that
we have earned so far together and apply
it and try a lab and solve the problem
so here's a problem statement
we need to create an s3 bucket for a
company where users can read or write
the data only if they are multi-factor
authenticated so there could be like 20
users in an account but a user is
allowed to read or write a data in an s3
bucket only if the user is multi-factor
authenticated you know this is a very
good use case if we have a sensitive
data in an s3 bucket and you only want
privileged or mfa authenticated users to
do changes to those buckets and for
those privileged users you would enable
multi-factor authentication so let's see
how that's done before that let me talk
to you a bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by aws
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes to level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an otp that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an rsa token key that
generates the one-time password that's
possible as well but in this case it's
the mobile phone now that's going to be
very similar to how we log in to our
gmail account sometimes when we log into
a gmail account and
i mean if you have the proper setting
enabled it's going to send an one-time
password to the mobile phone and only
after we put that information it's going
to let us log in let's see how all this
is done in an aws account so the first
thing is to login to the aws account
create a user and attach the user to the
virtual mfa device now we're going to
use google authenticator here and we're
going to attach the user to
google authenticator and make the user
use the google authenticator one-time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition to the
username and password that
he or she already has right so the first
thing is to log to the account connect
or sync the virtual appliance with the
aws username and password now when we
sync there will be an one-time password
that gets shown in the phone type in the
password in the aws console and then the
phone and the username comes to sync and
from that point onwards the user anytime
they log in they will have to propose
their username and password which is the
first step of security and then once
they typed in the username and password
type in the mfx code that gets generated
on the phone that would be the second
step or security or the last step of
security once that is done the account
is going to let them log in and access
the aws resources
alright so in order to test i am mfa s3
together this is what we're gonna do so
we're gonna create a bucket and we're
gonna have two users and we're gonna
allow or deny access to the s3 bucket to
those two users based on whether they
are mfa authenticated or not and on
purpose uh we gonna assign mfa to one
user and
no mfa to the other user like you might
have guessed by now the user with mfa
will have access to the bucket and the
user with no mfa attached will not have
access to the bucket both of them are
going to have full s3 services but mfa
like i said is one layer above the other
permissions mfa stands at all time so
irrespective of whether the underlying
policy says but they have full access to
the s3 bucket they're not going to
because mfa stands on top of it let's
see how that's done to begin with
firstly we need a bucket so let's create
a bucket
so i'm in my
aws console so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn mfa bucket and
let me put it in north virginia and
create
all right so that's done
now i'm going to put a separate folder
in here
i'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where i'm planning
to keep my tax files
and i only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the sd side it's partially done so
let's go back to i am
and here we're going to create two users
one a junior employee and another one
and a senior employee the senior
employee is the one who is going to have
mfa access and
more access to the s3 bucket and the
junior employee is the one who's not
going to have access to that particular
bucket so let's get
started let's create an user under iam
click on users
and let's create a user call as user
junior
right so here's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and
the user who creates the username and
the user are the same person so let's
keep it simple username password
management console access
and this user is going to have
full s3 bucket access all right this is
really the policy
and we should be familiar
with this json document by now it says
effect is allowed and what action any
action an s3 and
what resource anybody who is attached to
it
review
and create a user
so this user is having s3 full access
now let's create another user call them
as senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have s3 full access
all right so
both of them have s3 full access as we
see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this
senior employee now we're going to
attach
mfa to this employee so the way we would
do it is under the summary section of
that particular user click on security
credential and see here is a place we
can attach an mfa to this user so let's
attach mfa to this user
for mfa i can use both virtual mfa or
hardware mfa this being in lab
environment we're going to use virtual
mfa now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that i'm using
at the moment called google
authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so i can go to virtual mfa device and
once it is running i can scan the code
using the google authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that
is showing right here now that's going
to give us codes that we can use and we
will have to put in those codes here
twice we'll have to wait for some time
and it would generate a second set of
key that we can put
so my first set of key is four zero two
three five one right i'll have to wait
for some time and then it would throw me
a second set of key
it's like validating twice right here so
let me put in my second set of key
so this user is now mfa authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for mfa anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the mfa key along with it all right so
we're done with im what have we done
with im we have created two users both
of them have actually full access but
one of them have
mfa access and the other one does not
have mfa access and based on whether the
user is having mfa or not you know we
are identifying privileged users by this
mfa all right so based on whether the
user has mfa or not are we going to
allow deny access in the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged
folder part here i would like to
restrict access based on whether the
user is having mfa or not
so let me create a bucket policy here
now here is a policy that i have written
the policy
says that you know under tax document
folder give access only if the user is
mfa authenticated right if the user is
not mfa authenticated simply deny the
access to that user so as you might
guess right now the user one will not
have access or the
junior employee will not have access
because it's a privilege then you know
junior employee might tend to delete
them unknowingly and only privileged
users get access to the tax document
because it's confidential because it's
privileged because if it gets deleted we
won't be able to get it back for those
reasons right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the im url
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me login as the privileged user
sure enough i'm being asked for an mfa
code let me put my mfa code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim
forms sure enough i'm able to upload
content
into it will i be able to delete
yes i'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's login
as the other user
navigate to the sd bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for mfa
so navigate to the folder which we want
to test now try adding some files
as you see it's failing
to add content to this bucket it shows
error because the bucket policy is
requiring mfa and this user is not mfa
and we did that in iam or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with welcome to this new video lesson
where we're going to learn about cloud
formation in this section we're going to
learn about why we need a solution
called cloud formation or why we need a
product called cloud formation and we're
going to talk in detail about what is
cloud formation and then how cloud
formation works and the concepts
involved in cloud formation like you
know templates and stacks there are some
concepts involved in cloud formation
we're going to talk about that and how
do we maintain access control over cloud
formation we're going to talk about that
as well in this video and then we're
going to go through a demo or a lab
where we create an lamp stack
environment from a template through
cloud formation and then we're going to
talk about some use cases one of which
include
being able to create an redeployable
template using cloud formation that's a
very good use case we're going to talk
about that in this video so let's talk
about why cloud formation so when the
number of products and services grow
more and managing them and
maintaining them
becomes and tedious work and cloud
formation it sort of eases that
environment now cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a code and
it sort of solves all the problem that
we discussed some time back and with
cloud formation we can actually create a
perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily ember in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple aws
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
services it becomes an bigger task now
cloud formation eases that work let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is a
lot of time is being spent on building
the infrastructure and less focus and
less time at the moment is being given
on developing that application that runs
on that environment that's because
majority of the time is consumed by
building the environment and if we need
to redeploy the same environment again
and again the same happens in a cycle
again a new environment we start from
the scratch build environment and then
put application on top of it now that
can be avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of aws
resources by provisioning and updating
them in a very orderly and in a
predictable way if i need to expand
explanation of cloud formation cloud
formation is an service that really
helps us to model and set up our amazon
web services or resources so we can
spend less time on managing the
resources and show more focus on the
application that runs on top of it we
can simply create a template for an ec2
instance or for an rds instance and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation will provision and
configure those resources based on the
template that we define we really don't
have to sort out the complexities in
dependency between those applications
once the template is wetted and
validated cloud formation takes the
responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short at the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back end resources they run on
aws in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
infrastructure and more time on the core
business and the application that runs
on top of it and we're still talking
about what cloud formation is with cloud
formation it enables us to manage our
complete infrastructure or aws resource
in a text file now we're going to see
that in a moment you know it's either a
json or an yml file and that file is
called as the template to begin with the
resources the template provision is
called the stack all right so the
abstract of the code is called the
template and the resource that it
provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be i mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack gets done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
i'm including two more servers if i'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
i'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be embedded
in the update and can be updated so like
i said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the ec2
instance is provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning i can use the template in one
region and i can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region i can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care i'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about uh parameters mapping
and conditions down the line we're still
talking about aws how aws cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one requires a template and the template
would be in json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether they want a
load balancer based on what they want
and a windows server based on whether
they want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an s3 bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation uh to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes the template first
validates template and then it
identifies the
dependencies between them and then it
starts provisioning the resource one
after the other for example if you need
a five servers in a new vpc obviously
it's going to create the vpc first and
servers second and stack all right let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation by now you might have
guessed it the two major components are
the template and the stack together they
aid or they complement cloud formation
and that's how the resource of provision
that's how the resource are managed and
that eases the job of the administrator
who's managing the environment so let's
talk about template first a templated
cloud formation is an text file or a
formatted text file in json or yml
language and that the code or the
template or the text file that actually
describes how your infrastructure looks
like or will look like once provisioned
and for us to create the template or for
us to you know modify an existing
template we can use a tool available
called cloud formation designer from the
console or any text editing tool that's
available but i would recommend the
cloud formation designer though that has
rich graphics in it and these templates
are built off or they consist of nine
main objects the first of which is the
format version and this really
identifies the capabilities of the
template based on the version number and
then the second object in a template
would be description and this helps us
to include any arbitrary comments about
the template for what reason are we
building this template what's the
purpose of it stuff like that and then
we have the object called metadata in a
template and that includes a details
about the template details of the
resources in the template and then we
have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and
this transform section specifies one or
more transforms that we can use in our
cloud formation template for example uh
aws cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the aws
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required
section called resource that declares
the aws resource that you want to
include in the stack for example if you
want to include an ec2 instance if you
want to include an s3 bucket we would be
using the resource object in our stack
and then we have object call output this
output object it's an optional object in
the template and it helps us to sort of
uh declare the outputs that we can
import into other stacks or
we can actually show it on the cloud
formation console for example if you
want the output of the or the name of
the s3 bucket that got created in
response to a cloud formation template
now we can have that outputted into an
output section in the cloud formation
console itself so it's sort of easy for
us to identify the resources that the
template provisioned
so with all of those objects put
together this is how a full-blown cloud
formation template with all the objects
included is going to look like now this
includes optional and mandatory object
let's talk about those objects in detail
in the upcoming section all right let's
now discuss each and every object of
this template structure and let's begin
our discussion with the format version
the format version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010. now the
value of the template format version it
has to be and
string
and if you really don't specify the
format version cloudformation
automatically assumes the latest version
talking about description descriptions
are really any comments that help
ourselves that we want to embed in the
template itself that can be a
description and this description in a
template it has to be an string the
length of the string can be between
0 to 124 bytes in length the metadatas
are really used in the template to
provide any additional information using
the json and yaml objects and metadata
holds some implementation details of a
specific resource and parameters are
really a way to customize the template
each time we create or update our stack
these parameters are the ones that helps
us to give some custom value to the
template during runtime in the example
shown below the parameter named instance
type parameter it lets us to specify the
ec2 instance type for the stacks to use
when creating or updating the stack by
default as we see
it's picking t2 micro and this is the
value that will get picked if we don't
provision
another value to it and mapping mapping
really enables us to map a key to a
corresponding named value that we
specify in a conditional parameter and
also we can retrieve the map or to try
the values in the map using the function
find in map instrict function let's take
this example let's say based on a region
if you want to set values in a template
we can create a mapping that uses a key
and holds the value that you want to
specify for each region and the object
conditions can be used when we want to
reuse the templates by creating
resources in a totally different context
for example in a template during stack
creation all the conditions that we
mentioned in the template are evaluated
and any resources that are associated
and that come up to be true are created
and any condition that fails or invalid
are kind of ignored automatically and
the check moves forward to the next
condition and conditional is an optional
object and it includes statement that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is actually defined for
example you can create whether for
example you can compare whether a value
is equal to another value and based on
the result of that condition we can
conditionally create resources if you
have multiple conditions then they are
generally separated with commands
sometimes conditions are very helpful
when we want to create uh templates and
we want to reuse those templates which
was created for one environment to
another environment for example if you
want to use a template that was created
in a test environment in a dev
environment conditions would be helpful
for example in a production environment
we might want to include instances with
certain capabilities and in a test
environment we might want to include
instances with some reduced capability
in them for saving money and condition
helps us to sort of create resources
based on the environment it will be used
in we can also use intrinsic functions
to define conditions like equals we can
also use r conditions we can use not
functions intrinsic functions in a
condition and when put together the
syntax is going to look like the one
that you see on the screen now the
optional object called transform it
specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple
declarative language of aws cloud
formation with a powerful macro system
that helps us to
reuse the templates or the template
components and they really help us to
condense or simplify our codes by
enabling reuse of the template
components for example condense a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
aws resource that you want to include in
the stack such as ec2 instance such as
s3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are the logical id the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief the logical id is unique
within the template and the logical id
name it actually reference the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example and if
you want to map an elastic block store
volume or if you want to map and
name of the bucket in another place in
the template now then we would use the
logical id and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical id with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case mys3 bucket was named as mybucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies that the type
of the resource is an s3 bucket and the
properties are the additional
optional information that we can specify
to our resource for example if it is an
ec2 instance let's say we would like to
know which ami it used then property
section really defines the ami that was
used or ami as the property of the
instance so this section describes the
output value that needs to be imported
to other stacks or the output value that
needs to be shown in the console for the
user to easily navigate to the resource
that are being created for example uh
for a s3 bucket name we can declare an
output and once the bucket is created we
can actually
declare the output and sort of import
the name of the bucket in a different
place in the console so it's it's easy
to view instead of you know the user
getting confused and going to s3 and
searching for the bucket name this can
be made available in the cloudformation
console itself and the output fields it
can include some of these followings
like the logical id uh it's actually the
identifier of the current output and
it's very unique within the template and
it can also include a description
description is really a string type that
describes the output value and it can
also include value and value is the
property that was returned by the aws
cloud formation describe stacks command
all right let's talk about template
resource attribute in this section we're
going to uh talk about
attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have
if we need to name them we have a
creation policy and then we have
deletion policy it depends on metadata
attribute update policy attribute let's
talk about each of them separately when
we associate the create policy attribute
with the resource it actually delays the
resource configuration actions before
proceeding with the stack creation i
mean the attribute stack creation is
delayed till the time the cloud
formation receives some number of
success signals back i mean this is a
very good use case when we do auto
scaling
and this creation policy can be used
only with a
limited number of services like auto
scaling and ec2 instances
some of the use cases would be if you
want to install and software application
on an ec2 instance you might want the
applications to be running before it
proceeds further so in this case we
would use the creation policy attribute
to the instance and then send the
success signal after the applications
are installed and configured then cloud
formation goes to the next step here in
the syntax that we're looking at the
auto scaling creation policy and the
minimum successful instance percentage
it's actually a number of signals that
it will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting deleted and by
default if you don't have a delete
policy the uh data gets deleted just
like that but if you use an uh deletion
policy we would be able to preserve the
data by taking a snapshot of it or just
letting the resource and moving on with
deleting the other resources in the
stack and we specify the delete policy
attribute for each resource specifically
that we want to control and if there are
no deletion policy mentioned for a
particular resource the cloud formation
simply deletes the resources as that's
its default behavior and if you want to
keep the resource when the stack is
deleted we use we we mentioned retain in
the delete policy and that simply
retains the resource from getting
deleted so in this example we're
actually retaining a dynamodb table rest
of the resources in the stack will get
deleted and using the depends on
attribute
we actually
create a an order in which the resource
gets deleted for example if i map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the depends on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by an another when we
add the depends on attribute to a
resource the resource is created only
after the creation of the resource
specified by the depends on attribute
let's take this example in this example
we're saying that the resource x
depends on y we've said that x depends
on y so in this case when cloud
formation is executing it's going to
deploy y first because it has some
resources that depends on it so it's
going to create y first and then it's
going to create the resource called x on
the same context let's say in the
template we say that an ec2 is going to
depend on s3 and when the cloud
formation is executing it's going to
create an s3 bucket first and then the
ec2 instant that's probably because the
codes needed for the ec2 instance are
stored in the s3 bucket and and what
we're looking at is the syntax of how
the depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the bucket the other template
resource attribute is metadata metadatas
are the one that really helps us to
associate our resources with the the
structured data and by including this
attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
vpc and the metadata explains or
metadata defines that the vpc is part of
the region us east one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling group for example you're
looking at this uh sample where it says
that the update policy will it replace
the instance in an auto scaling group or
not so depending on what the value is
for the will replace section whether
it's true or false depending on that the
update policy will replace the instance
or will replace the auto scaling group
itself when it's doing and rolling
deployment now that we've discussed
about templates let's talk about aws
stacks as well now we know that aws
stacks are the actual resources that
gets generated or that gets created
because we ran a template right so stack
is a collection of aws results that we
can manage in a single unit in other
words you know we can create a stack
update a stack or delete a stack and
that would actually create update delete
the collection of resources within the
stack and all the resources in the stack
are really defined by the cloud
formation template and a stack for
instance can include all the resources
required to run a web application such
as a web server a database server and
some networking rules that come along
with it all that gets embedded in a
stack and let's say if we want to delete
all the resources that were created by
template that is in a separate stack we
can simply delete the stack and that
would sort of delete all the resources
that is in the stack so it sort of helps
us to manage all the resources in a
single unit or as a single unit so to
summarize stack is a collection of aws
resource and it can be managed as a
single unit and the cloud formations
template defines a stack in which the
resource can be created deleted or
updated in a very predictable way and a
stack can have all the resources like
web server database server vpc the
network and the security configurations
in a vpc all that is required to run a
web or a database application now stack
could be nested as well with cloud
formation we can actually
nest a stack with another stack and
that's going to create an hierarchy of
the stacks for example i mean this is a
very good picture that explains how the
stacks are nested in a hierarchical way
let's say stack p is the uh root stack
and that could be apparent
stack for
the stack called r and the stack call
cube and the same way the the stack call
r is a parent stack for the stack s and
the stack s is the parent stack for d
and q you get that right so stacks can
always be nested it's possible
cloudformation allows us to create a
microsoft windows stack based on amazon
ec2 windows amis and provide us with the
ability to install software and use
remote desktop to access our stack and
update the configuration of our stack
and these stacks can be run on windows
server instances there are a number of
pre-configured templates available and
it's directly available to use from the
aws website itself to name a few we have
templates available for sharepoint
running on an
windows server 2008 r2 we also have
templates that create a single server
installation of active directory running
on a windows server and in fact we have
templates available for elastic bean
stock and some sample applications that
runs from an windows server 2008 r2
let's talk about stack sets stack sets
actually has taken the stack level
implementation to the next level using
the aws cloud formation template we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack in aws account across the
globe by using just a single template
and after we create the stack or after
the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack in the
target account and the regions can also
be specified by us so the stack said it
really extends the functionality of the
stacks by allowing us to create update
and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can define and manage an aws
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
stacks into you know some selected
target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with im i can specify the
list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the
cloudformation template who can create
update and delete stacks so that's how
im helps me with having or putting a
layer of control over the cloud
formation service and we can also use
service roles service roles are the one
that allows aws cloud formation to make
a call to a resource in a stack on the
user's behalf and i can also have stack
policies and these stack policies are
applied to the users who already have
access to the cloud formation service
and these policies are the ones that
help the users who attempt to update the
stack all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local mysql database for
storage now we can do the other way as
well i can pick an ec2 instance and
install the servers one top of the other
that can be done as well but that's
going to take a lot of time now we're
talking about automating it we're
talking about you know provisioning and
infrastructure using a code and cloud
formation helps us to do that so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
create or we have a cloudformation
template already and we're going to use
that template the provision web instance
and that is going to have look at that
that's going to have my sql installed in
it that's going to have php that's going
to have httpd servers installed in it
and running and it's also going to have
an php website running from it so that's
going to receive information from the
website and that's going to store that
information in the database that's very
local to it
this is the template that defines
that environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision this
environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and
which region is it this is in
california is that
all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the mumbai region or let me switch to
north virginia region
north virginia and from here
actually let me switch to mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same
template that we are provisioning
all right let's give this a name so it's
going to be great it could be simply
long
simply learn lamp stack and what could
be the db password
and db root password
and what could be the db user
i'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and i'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
[Music]
password should only have alpha
numeric characters
get that
so let's go back and create a new
password
right it also needs to have
8 characters
so what can be your password
look at that the template is actually
creating the resources
and here in the screen
we can see the template that we used to
deploy the environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about
instant
types in parameters right
the default instance type is t2 small
but these are also allowed
to run
right parameter section is the one that
was
used to receive information from us like
the db name
the db password the db root password db
user instance type key name and ssh
locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually uh created
right looks like it's rolling back
why would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption
that it could not proceed it would
simply roll back and delete all the
resources that it had provisioned and
that's what it did
now let me fix this
all right as a fix i have switched uh
the region because i had some issue with
the vpc that's going to take time for me
to analyze and fix it so here we're
going to understand
about cloud formation so i thought i'll
run the cloud formation from another vpc
that
i know is working fine that's in north
virginia
all right let's provision a lamp server
which is running out of linux which has
apache installed on it which has php and
mysql already installed in it so one
server gonna act as web and db server
all right so i'm gonna create a stack
and from here i'm gonna pick a sample
stack
if we look at if we look at it in the
designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security at that security group
attached to it there you go right so
let's go ahead and create a stack
all right
parameters are used to receive
input from us what could be the db
password
and the db user
and
let's select the key name
right i'm going to keep the rest as
defaults
and i'm going to create
a stack
all right so our stack
that we run from the template
at the moment it's getting created it's
in progress
from here i can watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like i said in a lot of these would have
already sorted out their dependencies
you know which one needs to get created
first which one needs to get created
second
all that is sorted out by cloud
formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted
and a resource
tab
is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment so to begin with it created a
security group
at the moment it's creating an instance
and
output
uh it's empty as of now we're gonna come
back and see it now output is where
we can uh get outputs of a finished job
let's say uh here i wanted an uh url
of the
server
that got created so instead of me
uh you know going to a couple of other
places within the console and
find the
output of
the url
or
the the output of the resource that was
created i can simply get it from here
well this needs to be defined in the
templates first
once we define it in the template it's
going to be made available
like here
right so i can
open it
up and
there you go so it has it already has
a database locally installed and it's
connected to what if i launch an
application on top of it that will get
connected to the database which is very
local and
my
single
server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
uh creating an environment like this
which has elastic load balancer a vpc
a server running in an auto scaling
group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ec2
instances directly but they should be
able to access
the ec2 instance or the data only
through the elastic load balance so this
is a bit complicated than the
environment that we've already created
let's see how this is done all right in
this lab we're going to create elastic
load balanced auto scaling group which
is going to create a load balancer and
an auto scaling group and that auto
scaling group receives
traffic
only from the load balancer so here's
the template
and here's the architecture that we're
going to provision
let me call it
all right and the key pair it's going to
use is
simply learn key pair
now this is where the problem was now we
were selecting few subnets
so now if i provision it
now this is going to take its short time
to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good
no rollback no no deletes and the
resource section shows the resource that
it is creating so previously created a
target group now it's creating the
application load balancer itself
all right so it created an um
load balancer and that had created a
security group it created a launch
configuration it at the moment it's
creating a web server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or
roll back errors so it looks good all
right it took a while and
the resources have been created some of
them show that they are in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the url
there you go
thank you samuel for that wonderful
session i hope you guys found this
informative
we now have rahul who will take you
through the various certifications
available for you in aws
and then he will also guide you how you
can become an aws certified solutions
architect
over to you rahul
in today's job environment being
certified marks the difference between
getting your dream job and losing it if
you're a fresher or just someone who's
starting up it's highly likely that
you're confused in choosing the right
certification i'm going to help you
figure it out i'm rahul from simply
learn and today we're going to talk
about aws certifications so what exactly
is an aws certification it represents a
degree of expertise in aws it is
obtained after passing one or more exams
provided by amazon and each different
role like thesis ops administrator
developer or solutions architect has a
different exam associated with it this
in turn helps employees demonstrate and
validate technical cloud knowledge which
means that the people who are certified
actually know what they're talking about
i have seen a common misconception among
people where they believe that just
because they're certified they're
entitled the job that's not true now
without proper practice or hands-on
experience the certification is wasted
on you so remember just because you're
certified does not mean you'll get a job
it only makes the job application
process slightly easier related to
someone who's not been certified now why
is aws given so much importance some of
the important reasons are an aws
certified individual gains credibility
for their skills in aws they also gain
access to free practice exams which help
them prepare for the next aws
certification there's an increase in
monetary compensations which only means
that they get paid more and you gain
recognition for your knowledge and
skills in aws
right now we're in the aws certification
website whose link will be in the
description and now we're going to talk
about the types of aws certification as
you can see here there are three levels
of aws certification there's the
foundational level associate level and
professional level certification now the
foundational level certification only
requires you to have a basic
understanding of how the aws cloud works
the awa certified thought practitioner
is optional for the architect path
developer path and operations path it is
mandatory for the specialty
certifications like the advanced
networking big data and security
certifications now the associate level
certifications are mid-level
certifications for a technical role now
a professional certification is the
highest level of certification that you
can have for a technical role now you
have the solutions architect for the
architect path and the devops engineer
certification for both the developer and
operations path so how do you decide
which of these certifications is
suitable for you so you've seen here
that aws provides various certifications
for a number of job roles hexisops
administrator solution architect
developer so you need to make the right
choice taking into consideration the
areas of your interest and the
experience level that you have now we're
going to talk about each of these
certifications in detail so first let's
talk about the aw certified cloud
practitioner now we all understand that
aws is a widely recognized product in
the market so this certification helps
you validate how well you know the aws
cloud so this is just the basic
understanding now it is optional for the
developer path and the operations path i
would suggest it's a good idea to start
here because it forms a solid bedrock on
all the other things that you're going
to learn soon now more importantly it
does not require any technical knowledge
of other roles such as development
architecture administration and so on so
it's a great place to start for
newcomers now you have the architect
role certifications now this is for you
if you're interested in becoming a
solutions architect or a solution design
engineer or someone who just works with
designing applications or systems on the
aws platform now first we have the aws
certified solutions architect associate
level certification now this
certification is for you if you want to
show off how well you can architect and
deploy applications on the aws platform
now it is recommended that you have at
least a year of experience working with
distributed systems on the aws platform
at the same time it's also required that
you understand the aws services and be
able to recommend a service based on
requirements you need to be able to use
architectural best practices and you
need to estimate the aws costs and how
you can reduce them next up you have the
awa certified solutions architect
professional level certification now you
will not get the certification unless
you're done with the aw certified
solutions architect associate level
certification this is the show of your
technical skills and experience in
designing distributed applications on
the aws platform now this does require
you to have two years of experience
working with cloud architecture on aws
at the same time it also requires you to
be able to evaluate requirements and
then make architectural recommendations
you also need to provide guidance on the
best practices on architectural design
across a number of different platforms
the developer level certifications are
for you if you're interested in becoming
a software developer now the aws
certified developer associate
certification is to test how well you
know how to develop and maintain
applications on the aws platform it does
require you to have a year or more of
hands-on experience to design and
maintain aws based applications like any
software developer role it is necessary
that you know in-depth at least one
high-level programming language it's
also necessary that you understand the
core of aws services uses and basic
architectural best practices you need to
be able to design develop and deploy
cloud-based solutions on aws platform
and you need to understand how
applications can be created you need to
have experience in developing and
maintaining applications for a number of
aws services like amazon sns dynamodb
sqs and so on now for the aws certified
devops engineer professional level
certification note here that this
certification is exactly the same as the
one you have under the operations role
so both of them are the same thing so
here it tests your ability to create
operate and manage distributed
applications on the aws platform now it
is necessary or it is mandatory to have
the aws certified developer associate
certification or the aws certified
sysops administrator certification with
two or more years of hands-on experience
in doing the same in aws environments it
requires you to be able to develop code
in at least one high level language you
need to be able to automate and test
applications via scripting and
programming and to understand agile or
other development processes the
operation certifications are for you if
you want to become a sysops
administrator systems administrator or
someone in devops role who wants to
deploy applications networks and systems
in an automatable and beatable way the
aw certified sysops administrator
associate certification tests your
knowledge in deployment management and
operations on the aws platform now you
need to have one or more years of
hands-on experience in aws based
applications you need to be able to
identify and gather requirements then
define a solution to be operated on aws
you need to be able to provide guidance
for the best practices through the life
cycle of a project as well now the
specialty certifications are for you if
you're well-versed in aws and want to
showcase your expertise in other
technical areas the aw certified big
data certification showcases your
ability to design and implement aws
services which can help derive value
from a large amount of complex data you
are however required to have completed
the foundational or associate level
certification before you can attempt
this you need a minimum of five years of
hands-on experience in the data and
analytics field as well next we have the
aw certified advanced networking
certification this validates your
ability to design and implement aws
solutions as well as other hybrid id
network architectures at scale this also
requires you to have completed the
foundational or associate level
certification you need to have a minimum
five years of hands-on experience
architecting and implementing network
solutions and lastly we have the aw
certified security certification it
helps showcase your ability to secure
the aws platform you're required to have
an associate or cloud practitioner level
of certification a minimum of five years
of it security experience and two years
of hands-on experience securing aws
workloads now say i wanted to schedule
an examination so for example i want to
do the solutions architect certification
so first i would go there now here i can
click on register now and the process
continues or i can click on learn more
by doing this again i can show you the
examination here i can also get access
to other data like the number of
questions available the cost of an
examination the portions i need to study
and so on now let's talk about solutions
architect certification with a little
more detail now this certification exam
cost 150 us dollars and the practice
exam cost 20 us dollars now here i can
schedule the examination or download the
exam guide i've already downloaded the
exam guide and here it is now this exam
guide tells you about what you need to
learn and what is expected from you here
they want you to define a solution based
on requirements and provide guidance in
its implementation it is also
recommended that you know about how the
aws services work one years of hands-on
experience with distributed systems on
aws to identify and define technical
requirements and so on the rest is
available in the exam guide and most
importantly they tell you the main
content domains and their weightages now
we have five domains first domain is to
design resilient architectures which
holds 34 percent of weightage at depend
two you have to define performance
architectures three is to specify secure
applications and architectures cost
optimized architectures and five to
define operationally excellent
architectures now like you've seen here
you've selected one certification and
learnt it in detail you can do the same
for any of these other certifications
and today i'm going to tell you how you
can become an aws solutions architect so
who is an aw solutions architect now the
main role of an aws solutions architect
is to help you deploy your applications
on the aws platform now this is nothing
but a cloud computing platform so it's
not to say that you can't deploy your
applications on the cloud computing
platform yourself it's just that when it
comes to organizations the applications
that you need to deploy become a whole
lot more complex that's where an aw
solutions architect can help ever since
cloud computing became a thing companies
around the world have started migrating
their physical infrastructure onto the
cloud that's what an aw solutions
architect does they help you migrate
your physical infrastructure onto the
aws cloud companies around the world
work on a budget an aw solutions
architect will help design a cloud
infrastructure based on the
organization's budget before that can be
done however an aws solutions architect
has to create a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now aw solutions architects also have to
focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability reliability
scalability and performance of the cloud
infrastructure they're also responsible
when it comes to minimizing risks that
an organization can face when it comes
to cloud computing platforms now they
could face risks like security leaks
calculation mistakes and application
down times an aw solutions architect has
to ensure that these don't happen before
we can talk about how you can become an
aws solutions architect i have some
exciting news for you guys we've
launched our own youtube community
you'll get to see a lot of quizzes polls
offers and much more to make your
learning experience a whole lot more fun
you can find all of this on your
subscription feed or you can also click
on the top right corner right now to get
started and let's get back to how can
you become an aws solutions architect
now to become an aw certified solutions
architect you need to clear the aw
certified solutions architect associate
level examination now here's some
details about it the exam score ranges
from 100 to 1000 marks and the minimum
passing score is 720. however there's a
catch the passing marks are actually set
using statistical analysis so they can
be changed based on how difficult the
examination actually is the exam fee is
150 dollars and you can also take a
practice examination which costs 20
dollars now regardless of the
examination you take be it solutions
architect sysops administrator or
developer any associate level
examination costs 150 dollars for the
professional level examination it's 300
now if you want to learn more about the
aws certifications i suggest you click
on the top right corner and watch our
video aw certifications in 10 minutes to
learn more now the exam duration is of
130 minutes and you have two types of
questions multiple choice and multiple
answer now the multiple choice questions
have four options on which one of them
is right and you have multiple answer
where you have five options out of which
two of them are correct you can take the
examination in english japanese korean
and simplify chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination
first let's go to google and search for
aws certifications
click on the first link
so on this page you can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications it
place provides
click on architect
and select the awa certified solutions
architect associate certification click
on register now
and here you need to click on the aw
certification account
you can sign in with your amazon account
or create a new one
i already have an amazon account that
i'll be using for signing in here in
case you don't you can click on the
create your amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
after that is done you can schedule a
new examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here aw certified solutions architect
associate level certification
click on schedule exam
press continue
and here you need to select your
language
which i'm assuming is english
i'm from india so i don't need to change
anything here but you can change your
country your time zone and other details
based on your requirement
and select your preferred month i want
to do it in october
now select search for exam center
select the one that's closest to you
i'm going to select this one
and here you can select the day that you
want to take your test and the time
available i want to do it on 15
select the time that i want
and press continue
now you can go through all the details
here
change them if you want to otherwise you
can press continue
after this is done
close
and here we have the final step
which is the fees
you can enter your details here
and pay now to finish the process
now let's look at an outline of the exam
content now what you're going to see in
the exam are five major domains and here
you have each of the domains with their
respective weightages first you have at
34
designing resilient architectures at 24
percent you have both defining
performant architectures and specifying
secure applications and architectures at
10 percent you have designing cost
optimized architectures and at six
percent you have defining operationally
excellent architectures now let's look
at each of these domains in detail now
the first domain or design resilient
architectures can be divided into four
parts firstly you need to know how you
can choose reliable or resilient storage
using services like aws s3 aws glacier
and aws ebs then you have how you can
design decoupling mechanisms using aws
services now this is possible with the
help of aws sns now these aren't the
only services that enable this these are
just some of the services then how you
can design a multi-tier architecture
solution now this is important because
you need to know how you can create a
solution that involves several other
services then you need to know how you
can design highly available and fault
tolerant architectures now for the
second domain defining performant
architectures first you have how to
choose performance storages and
databases services that are used are aws
rds aws redshift and aws dynamodb the
second step is how you can apply caching
to improve performance a service that
can be used for this is aws elastic
cache third how you can design solutions
with elasticity and scalability you have
aws lambda aws cloudwatch and aws data
pipeline now for the third domain which
is specifying secure applications and
architectures you need to know how you
can secure applications using services
like aws inspector aws cloudtrail and
aws iam you need to know how to secure
data using cloud hsm and aws macy and
how you can define the networking
infrastructure using cloudfront vpc and
elastic load balancer for the fourth
domain you have designing cost optimized
architectures firstly you need to know
how you can design cost optimized
compute solutions you can use aws ec2
elastic bean stock lambda and aws light
sale then you need to know how you can
design cost optimized storage solutions
using aws s3 glacier ebs and elastic
file system and the final domain to
define operationally excellent
architectures you need to set up design
features and solutions that enable
operational excellence now some of the
features are that you perform operations
as code you annotate documentation you
make frequent and small reversible
changes and anticipate and tackle
failures now let's have a look at the
job opportunities when it comes to aw
solutions architects now if you have a
look at this graph you can see that aws
has always provided a lot more job
postings as compared to the other two
giants in the cloud computing domain
which are microsoft azure and google
cloud platform now if you do a little
bit of research you'll find out that
there's a significant lacking of
experienced personnel when it comes to
aws so i would suggest this is the best
time for you to get certified in aws so
how can simply learn help you with your
aws certifications now we are on the
sampler on home page
and here we have the aws solutions
architect course
on this course which is the aws
solutions architect certification
training course we have 36 hours of
instructor-led training 20 hours of
self-paced learning 16 live demos three
simulation exams three hands-on practice
projects and so much more here our main
emphasis is on making sure that you have
enough hands-on experience with the
services that you crack the examination
at your first attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like iam vpc ec2 s3 and so much
more we'll also talk about databases
application services security practices
disaster recovery and so on we even have
practice examinations to help you
prepare for the real one thank you very
much rahul that was great
we have now reached the final segment of
this complete aws tutorial
we will now have samuel take you through
80 of the most important aws questions
that might just appear in your aws or
cloud interview i'm here to walk you
through some of the aws interview
questions which we find are important
and our hope is that you would use this
material in your interview preparation
and be able to crack that cloud
interview and step into your dream cloud
job by the way i'm and cloud technical
architect trainer and an interview
panelist for cloud network and devops so
as you progress in watching
you're going to see that these questions
are practical scenario based questions
that tests the depth of the knowledge of
a person in a particular aws product or
in a particular aws architecture so why
wait let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the aws products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as advanced services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the aws products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is lambda
auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run any application and the compute
service helps us in managing the scaling
and deployment of an application again
lambda is a compute server so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are s3
object storage glacier for archiving ebs
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
efs file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be glacier and any object
files and any requirement for block
storage can be met through elastic block
store and s3 which is again an object
storage
talking about networks it's just not
important to answer the question with
the name of the services and the name of
the product it'll also be good if you
could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain
vpc networking can't imagine networking
without vpc in in the cloud environment
especially in aws cloud environment and
then we have route 53 for domain
resolution or
for dns and then we have cloud front
which is an edge caching service that
helps customers get or customers to read
their application with low latency so
networking domain helps with some of the
following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the aws
services within our account and we can
also pick an ip address range
if you're a network engineer or if you
are somebody who works in networks or
planning to work the network you will
soon realize the importance of choosing
your own ip address for easy remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud owned range of ip
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that gets asked would
be the difference between the
availability zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked
so to test how well you can actually
differentiate and also correlate the
availability zone and the region
relationship right so a region is a
separate geographic area like the us2s1
i mean which represents uh not
california
or the ap south which represents mumbai
so regions are a separate geographic
area on the contrary availability zone
resides inside the region you shouldn't
stop there you should go further and
explain about availability zones and
availability zones are isolated from
each other and some of the services will
replicate themselves within the
availability zone so availability zone
does replication within them but regions
they don't generally do replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is what is auto scaling
what do we achieve by auto scaling so in
short auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular r now this helps business in
not worrying about
putting more effort in managing or
continuously monitoring the server to
see if they have the needed resource or
not because auto scaling is going to
handle it for us so business does not
need to worry about it and auto scaling
is one big reason why people would want
to go and pick a cloud service
especially an aws service the ability to
increase and shrink based on the need of
that art that's how powerful is auto
scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's your targeting in cloud front
now we know that cloudfront is caching
and it caches content globally in the
amazon caching servers global wide the
whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest server possible that's the whole
point in using or going for cloudfront
then what do you mean by geotargeting
geotargeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in that place we can
actually customize the content the url
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or a
specific country code it will change the
content and it will send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or backing up
an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an x3 bucket s3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the s3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloudformation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource b what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource b first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it could roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
provisions those service first and then
provisions the services that has
dependencies and if you're being hired
for
a devops or you know if the interview
wanted to test your skill on
systems side this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody is moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that i can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is
going to cause a downtime right so
that's you should be answering or you
shouldn't be thinking in those terms
because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger uh ec2 instance type over the
bigger capacity and install all that's
needed if you are going to use an ami of
the old machine well and good you don't
have to go through installing all the
updates and installing all the
application from the ami once you've
launched it in a bigger instance locally
test the application to see if it is
working don't put it on production yet
test the application to see if it is
working and if the application works we
can actually swap if your server is
behind and
behind uh
route 53 let's say all that you could do
is go to dot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cutover is handled or if
you're using static ip you can actually
remove the static ip from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic nic card you can actually
remove the new card from the old machine
and attach the new card to the new
machine so that way we would get near
zero downtime if you're hired for an
architect level
you should be worrying about cost as
well along with the technology and this
question would test how well you manage
cost so what are the tools and
techniques we can use in aws to identify
and correct identify and know that we
are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are using or how do
you get a visibility of your aws
resources running one way is to check
the billing there is a place where you
can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so i'm using a
lot of storage i'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that should be
storing and then clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget
alright this is how much i am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget mark and any time it exceeds any
time it's nearing you would get an alarm
saying that well we're about to reach
the allocated budget amount stuff like
that that way you can go back and know
and you know that how much the bill is
going to be for that month or you can
take steps to control bill amount for
that particular month so aws budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tax the dev team has spent so
much the uh production team has spent so
much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that now you'll be able to you know
think in those levels only if you have
cost allocation tax now cost allocation
tags are nothing but the tags that you
would put when you create a resource so
for production services you would put as
a production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource other than
the console console is gui right so in
other words other than gui how would you
use the aws resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the aws resource are of course
footy you can configure putty to access
the aws resources like log into an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use putty to log into
an ec2 instance and like the jump box
like the proxy machine and like the
gateway machine and from there you can
actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an alternative to
the console and of course we have the
aws cli in any of the linux machines or
windows machines we can install so
that's point two three and four we can
install aws cli for linux windows also
for mac so we can install them and from
there from your local machine we can
access run aws commands and access
provision monitor the aws resources the
other ones are we can access the aws
resource programmatically using aws sdk
and eclipse so these are a bunch of
options we have to use the aws resource
other than the console if you're
interviewed in a company or by a company
that focuses more on security and want
to use aws native services for their
security then you would come across this
question what services can be used to
create a centralized logging solution
the basic services we could use our
cloudwatch logs store them in s3 and
then use elasticsearch to visualize them
and use kinesis to move the data from s3
to elasticsearch right so log management
it actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs
instead of logging into an instance or
instead of logging into the environment
and checking the resources physically i
can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
cloud watch pushes it to s3 kinesis
pushes the data from s3 to elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one or whatever the time window
that i wanted to look at so it helps in
getting a good understanding of the
infrastructure as a whole all the logs
are getting saved in one place so all
the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect to each other
it could be logs that belongs to a one
account it could be logs that belongs to
multiple accounts doesn't matter you
know those three services are gonna work
fairly good and they're gonna inject or
they're gonna like suck logs from the
other accounts put it in one place and
help us to monitor so as you see you
have cloud watch here that actually
tracks the metrics you can also use
cloud trail if you want to log api calls
as well push them in an s3 bucket so
there are different types of blog flow
logs are getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client
so step one is to deploy the ecs cluster
step two is to restrict access to the
ecs cluster because it's valid data you
don't want anybody to put their hands
and access their data so resting access
to the ecs dashboard and we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloud watch to
the elasticsearch domain and then kibana
is actually the graphical tool that
helps us to visualize the logs instead
of looking at log as just statements or
in a bunch of characters a bunch of
files kibana helps us to analyze the
logs in a graphical or a chart or a bar
diagram format again in an interview the
interviewer's more concerned about
testing your knowledge on aw security
products especially on the logging
monitoring even management or incident
management then you could have a
question like this what are the native
aws security logging capabilities now
most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like s3 s3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging ds has
its own logging vpc has its own logging
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and aws config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the aws like cloud
trail config cloudfront redshift logging
rds logging vpc flow logs s3 object
logging s3 access logging stuff like
that so we're going to look at two
servers in specific cloud trail now this
cloud trail the very first product in
that picture we just thought the cloud
trail provides an very high
level history of the api calls for all
the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis a security analysis of our
account and these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to s3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also send an email
notification to us saying hey just got
this error thought i'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service a config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aws config
all right the other question you could
get asked is if
you know your role includes taking care
of cloud security as well then the other
question you could get asked is the
native services that amazon provides or
to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service now not all companies would go
with amazon native services but there
are some companies which want to stick
with amazon native services just to save
them from the headache of managing the
other softwares or bringing in another
tool a third-party tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legitimate users access
the servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of what denial of services now
look at it these users instead of making
one connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legitimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
will keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is uh
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in aws is cloud shield
and web access firewall aw survive now
they are the major ones they are
designed to mitigate a denial of service
if your website is often bothered by
denial of service then we should be
using aws shield or aws vaf and there
are a couple of other tools that also
does when i say that also does denial of
service is not their primary job but you
could use them for denial of service
route 53's purpose is to provide dns
cloudfront is to provide caching elastic
load balancer elbs work is to provide
load balancing vpc is to create and
secure a virtual private environment but
they also support mitigating denial of
service but not to the extent you would
get in aws shield and aws web so aws
shield and waff are the primary ones but
the rest can also be used to mitigate
distributed denial of service the other
tricky question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region so when you're
trying to provision a service in a
particular region you're not seeing the
service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
america north virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california so within not america itself
north virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime we don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it you
could but you know that's going to add
more latency to your application so
that's why we need to check for
application which is check for region
which is very near to the place where
you want to serve your customers and
find nearest region instead of always
going back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again there's a place there's a
link in aws.com that you can go and look
for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest other region that
provides that service and start using
service from there
with the
coming up of cloud a lot of companies
have turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment now they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage aws
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a monitor to
monitor the website metrics in real time
in aws the simple way anytime you
have a question about monitoring
cloudwatch should strike your mind
because cloudwatch is meant for
monitoring is meant for collecting
metrics is meant for providing graphical
representation of what's going on in a
particular network at a particular point
of time so cloudwatch cloudwatch helps
us to monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are there are more services added
there is a reduction in the number of
servers because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloud watch any cloud watch can
now support scheduled events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action all
right schedule a trigger time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with cloud watch so this cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment this cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can monitor and
based on what's happening it can trigger
an event in lambda and that would in
turn run a function till the environment
comes back to normal so cloudwatch
integrates well with a lot of other aw
services
all right so cloudwatch has uh three
statuses green when everything is going
good lo when the service is degraded and
red when the service is not available
green is good so we don't have to do
anything about it but anytime there's an
ello the picture that we're looking at
it's actually calling and lambda
function to debug the application and to
fix it and anytime there's a red alert
it immediately notifies the
owner of the application about well the
service is down and here is the report
that i have here is the metrics that
i've collected about the service stuff
like that if the job role requires you
to manage the servers as well there are
certain job roles which are on the
system side there are certain job roles
which is development plus system side
now you're responsible for the
application and the server as well so if
that's the case you might be tested with
some basic questions like the different
types of virtualization and aws and what
are the difference between them all
right the three major types of
virtualization are hvm which is hardware
virtual machine the other one is pv para
virtualization and the third one is pv
on hvm para virtualization on hardware
virtual module
all right the difference between them or
actually describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm it's
actually a fully virtualized hardware
you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the pva mice and when we
talk about pv on hvm it's it's actually
the marriage between hvm and pv and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words pv on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host
another good question is name some of
the services that are not a region
specific now
you've been thought that all services
are within a region and some services
are within an availability zone for
example ec2 is within an availability
zone ebs is within an availability zone
s3 is region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that vpc is both
availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and vpcs
region specific stuff like that so you
might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non-region and availability
non-availability services i should say
there are services that are not region
specific that would be iam so we can't
have im for every availability zone and
for every region which means you know
users will have to use one username and
password for one region and anytime they
switch to another region they will have
to use another username and password
that that's more work and that's not a
good design as well authentication has
to be global so im is a global service
and which means its not region specific
on the other hand route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have a
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region specific service it's a
global service and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each region
if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region based service so
the web application firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service though you can you know cache
content on a continent and country basis
it's still considered a global service
right it's not bound to any region so
when you activate cloud front you're
activating it away from region or
availability zone so when you're
activating a web application firewall
because it's not a region-specific
service you're activating it away from
availability zone and regions
so a quick recap i am users groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used globally
all 53 services are offered at edge
locations and they are global as well
web application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are global service as
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery network cdn and they
are offered at edge locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific service or beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using nat or if they are already
securing their environment using nat by
any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a nat gateway and that instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them right
on a high level they both achieve
providing netting for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about
the availability of it
that gateway is a managed service by
amazon whereas nat instance is managed
by us now i'm talking about the third
point maintenance here nat gateway is
managed by amazon that instance is
managed by us and availability of nat
gateway is very high and availability of
that instance is less compared to the
nat gateway because it's managed by us
you know it's on an ec2 instance which
could actually fail and if it fails
we'll have to relaunch it but if it is
not gateway if something happens to that
service amazon would take care of
reprovisioning it and talking about
bandwidth it can burst up to 75 gigabits
now traffic through the net gateway can
burst up to 75 gigabits but for that
instance it actually depends on the
server that we launched and if we are
launching a t2 micro it barely gets any
bandwidth so there's a difference there
and the performance because it's highly
available because of the bigger pipe 75
gigabits now the performance of the net
gateway is very high but the performance
of the nat instance is going to be
average again it depends on the size of
the net instance that we pick and
billing a billing for nat gateway is the
number of gateways that we provision and
the duration for which we use the nat
gateway but billing for that instance is
number of instance and the type of
instance that we use of course number of
instance duration and the type of
instance that we use
security not gateway cannot be uh
assigned meaning it already comes with
full backed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
i can go and change the security because
it's a server managed by me or managed
by us i can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the
night gateway is uniform but the size
and the load of the uh that instance
changes as per that gateway is a fixed
product but not instance can be small
instance can be a big instance so the
size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stopped state but when
you actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop state the
ebs volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and we'll never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even a cloud
consultant level position or even in an
engineering position this is a very
common question that gets asked what are
the different types of easy to instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity for example
the different types are on demand
instances spot instances and reserved
instances it kind of looks the same they
all provide the compute capacity they
all provide the same type of hardwares
for us but if are looking at cost saving
or optimizing cost in our environment we
got to be very careful about which one
are we picking now we might think that
well i'll go with on-demand instance
because i pay on a per hour basis which
is cheap you know i can use them anytime
i want and anytime i don't want i can
simply get rid of it by terminating it
you're right but if the requirement is
to use the service for one year the
requirement is to use the service for
three years then you'll be wasting a lot
of money buying on-demand instances
you'll be wasting a lot of money paying
on an hourly basis instead we should be
going for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances all right so under man is
cheap to start with if you're only
planning to use it for a short while but
if you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per r this is very short term
and irregular workloads and for testing
for development on demand instance is a
very good use case we should be using
on-demand for production spot instance
spot instance allows users to purchase
ec2 at a reduced price and anytime we
have more instances we can always go and
sell it in spot instances i'm referring
to anytime we have more reserved
instances we can always sell them in
spot instance catalog and the way we buy
spot instance is we actually put a
budget this is how much i'm willing to
pay all right would you be able to give
service within this cost so anytime the
price comes down and meets the cost that
we have put in will be assigned an
instance and anytime the price shoots up
the instance will be taken away from us
but in case of on demand instances we
have bought that instance for that
particular r and it stays with us but
with spot instances it varies based on
the price if you meet the price you get
the instance if you don't meet the price
goes away to somebody else and the spot
instance availability is actually based
on supply and demand in the market
there's no guarantee that you will get
spot instance at all time all right so
that's a caveat there you should be
familiar with that's a caveat that you
should be aware when you are proposing
somebody that we can go for spot
instance and save money it's not always
going to be available if you want your
spot instance to be available to you
then we need to carefully watch the
history of the price of the spot
instance now how much was it last month
then how much was it how much is it this
month so how can i code or how much can
i code stuff like that so you got to
look at those history before you propose
somebody that well we're going to save
money using spot instance on the other
hand reserved instance provide cost
savings for the company we can opt for
reserved instances for you know one year
or three years there are actually three
types of reserved instances light medium
and heavy reserved instances they are
based on the amount that we would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on are we doing all
upfront or no upfront or partial payment
then split the rest as monthly payments
so there are many purchase options
available but overall if you're looking
at using an application for the next one
year and three years you should not be
going for on-demand instance you should
be going for reserved instance and
that's what gives you the cost benefit
and in an aws interview sometimes you
might be asked you know how you interact
with the aws environment are you using
cli are you using console and depending
on your answer whether console or a cli
the panelist put a score okay this
person is cli specific this person is
console specific or this person has used
aws environment through the sdk stuff
like that so this question tests whether
you are a cli person or an console
person and the question goes like this
how do you set up ssh agent forwarding
so that you do not have to copy the key
every time you log in if you have used
puri anytime if you want to log into an
ec2 instance you will have to put the ip
and the port number along with that you
will have to map or we will have to map
the key in the puri and this has to be
done every time that's what we would
have done in our lab environments right
but in production environment using the
same key or mapping the same key again
and again every time it's actually an
hassle it's considered as a blocker so
you might want to cache it you might
want to permanently add it in your putty
session so you can immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your ssh to
your putty instance so we can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key to the ssh and next time when we
try to log in you don't have to always
go through mapping the key and trying to
log in all right this question what are
solaris and ax operating systems are
they available with aws that question
generally gets asked to test how
familiar are you with the
amis available how familiar are you with
ec2 how familiar are you with the ec2
hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with aws i've
seen windows i've seen ubuntu i've seen
red hat i've seen amazon amis and if i
don't see my operating system there i
can always go to marketplace and try
them if i don't find a marketplace i can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available i will be
able to find solaris and ax but that's
not the case solar s and ax are not
available with aws that's because
solaris uses a different and solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power cpu and not on intel and as of now
amazon does not provide power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a high performance computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different hardwares different
cpu itself that the cloud providers they
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate their
infrastructure using amazon native
services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing
bugs in an os stuff like that you know
once an ec2 instance crashes like it
goes on a ospanic
there are various reasons why it would
fail so we don't have to really worry
about fixing it we can always relaunch
that instance and that would fix it but
what if it happens at two o'clock in the
night what if it happens at during a
weekend when nobody's in office looking
or monitoring those instances so you
would want to automate that not only on
a weekend or during midnight but it's
general practice good to automate it so
you could face this question how do you
actually automate an ec2 instance once
it fails and the answer to that question
is using cloudwatch we can recover the
instance so as you see there is an alarm
threshold a set in cloudwatch and once
the threshold is met meaning if there is
an error if there is a failure if the
ec2 instance is not responding for a
certain while we can set an alarm and
once the alarm is met let's say the cpu
utilization stayed high for five minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like i'm going
to do it so the other option is stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets i mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the cpu
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or cpu is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of ami designs there are
a lot of ami designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back amis and the other one is just
enough os ami je os ami and the other
one is hybrid type amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's
ready to use ami and this is the
simplest ami to deploy can be a bit
expensive it can be a bit cumbersome
because you'll have to do a lot of work
beforehand you could use the ami so a
lot of planning a lot of thought process
will go into it and the ami is ready to
use right you hand over the ami to
somebody and it's ready to use or if you
want to reuse the ami it's already ready
for you to use so that's full baked ami
the other one is just enough operating
system ami just like the name says
it has
i mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible i can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment the other one is a hybrid ami
now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between the fully baked ami and just
enough operating system options so these
amis have some features of the big type
and some features of the just enough os
type so as you see the security
monitoring logging
are
packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed during the
time of a deployment so this is where
the strict company policies would go
into the ami company policies like you
gotta log this you gotta monitor this
these are the ports that generally gets
open in all the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an amf format and during
deployment you have the flexibility of
choosing the different runtime and the
application that sits in an ec2 instance
another very famous question you would
face in an interview is how can you
recover login to an ec2 instance to
which you lost the key well we know that
if the key is lost we can't recover it
there are some organizations that
integrate their ec2 instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the 80 and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup button here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise the ticket with
amazon not possible they're not going to
help it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the easy to
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run in that ec2
instance and then detach the root volume
for that instance of course it's going
to require a stop and start to detach
the root volume from the instance attach
the root volume to another instance as a
temporary volume or it could be a
temporary instance that you've launched
only to fix this issue and then log in
to that instance and to that particular
volume and modify the configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key and then move the root volume
back to its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can log in so that's how we go ahead
and fix it now let's move on to some
product specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably and the
interviewer would want to test your
knowledge on s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences between aws s3 and ebs well
the differences are s3 is an object
store meaning you can't install anything
in it you can store drive files but you
can't actually install in it it's not a
file system but ebs is a file system you
can install services i mean install
applications in it and that's going to
run stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because from the instance if
you need to access s3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the s3 or s3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your vpc to access s3 s3 does
not come under a vpc but ebs comes under
a vpc it's on the same vpc so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to s3 ebs is very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
s3 and ebs s3 is
replicated the data in s3 is replicated
across the data centers but ebs is
replicated within the data center
meaning s3 is replicated across
availability zones ebs is within an
availability zone so that way the
redundancy is a bit less in ebs in other
words bluetooth nc is higher in s3 than
ebs and talking about security of s3 is3
can be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access s3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but ebs can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas s3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to s3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to assert in a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he's
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we would actually uh put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put a tag on them put a tag saying well
they are highly critical they are medium
critical and they are not critical at
all still there in production stuff like
that and then you would pick the users
who wants to or who should be or should
not be given access to a certain server
and you would actually allow the user to
access or not access servers based on a
specific tag in other words you can use
actually tags in in the previous step we
put tags on the critical server right so
you would define that this user is not
going to use this tag right this user is
not allowed to use the resources with
this stack so that's how you would make
your step forward so you would allow or
deny based on the tags that you have put
so in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are tagged
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them and the same goes
for bucket as well
if an organization is excessively using
s3 for their data storage because of the
benefit that it provides the cost and
the
durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having a data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for dr purposes for
disaster recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users who are local to that region
stuff like that so when companies do
replication how do you make sure that
there is consistency in the replication
how do you make sure that the
replication is not failing and the data
gets transferred for sure and there are
logs for that replication this is
something that the companies would use
where they're excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on the replication
in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have region two and region
one is the source bucket and region two
is the destination bucket right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or or made a copy in the region
to bucket and the problem is sometimes
it fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these services together and
create and cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloud watts
that make sure that the data is uh moved
no data is failing again there's cloud
watch on the other end make sure that
the data is moving and then we have the
logs generated through cloudtrail and
that's actually written in dynamodb and
if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an sms
or you get notified through an email
using the sns service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc is that we all
know that i can use route 53 to resolve
an ip address externally from the
internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom dns name that it does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
gonna discuss so the question could be a
vpc is not resolving the server through
the dns you can access it through the ip
but not through the dns name and what
could be the issue and how do you go
about fixing it and you will be able to
answer this question only if you have
done it already it's a quick and simple
step by default vpc does not allow
that's the default feature and we will
have to enable the
dns hostname resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns that comes along this is
for the custom dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution so
our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution so they actually resolve
let's say i want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to server
one simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and they have a head office in a
central place and the rest of them are
branch offices and they are connecting
to the head office for access or you
know for saving data or for accessing
certain files or certain data or storing
data all right so they would actually
mimic the hub and spoke topology where
you have the vpc which is centrally in
an accessible region a centrally
accessible region and then you would
have a local vpcs or branch offices in
different other regions and they get
connected to the vpc in the central
location and the question is how do you
actually connect the multiple sites to a
vpc and make communication happen
between them by default it does not do
that we know that vpcs they need to be
paired between them in order to access
the resources let's look at this picture
right so i have like a customer network
or branch offices in different parts and
they get connected to a vpc that's fine
so what we have achieved is those
different offices the remote offices
they are connecting to the vpc and
they're talking but they can't connect
or they can't talk to each other that's
what we have built but the requirement
is the traffic
needs to or they should be able to talk
to each other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit the vpc and then
reach the other customer network which
is in los angeles or which is in new
york all right that's the requirement so
that's possible with some architecting
in the cloud so that's using vpn cloud
hub you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows customers or which
actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the vpc again by default it
doesn't happen cloud hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the vpc or headquarters data center
which is in the vpc you have control or
the vpc has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to i mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the vpc the other question
you could get asked is neyman explain
some security products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
vpc or the vpc delivers those products
to secure the application
access to the vpc is restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security product in vpc
and a vpc has security groups that
protects the instances from unwanted
inbound and outbound traffic and network
access control list protects the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access and there are flow logs we can
capture in vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a vpc which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern and stuff like that
so there are some security products and
features available in vpc now how do you
monitor vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc except for lambda
and s3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a vpc for
security reason so how do you monitor
your vpc how do you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc using vpc flow log that's the
basic service as you see it actually
captures what's allowed what's not
allowed stuff like that which ips
allowed which ip is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis
and the other one is cloud watch and
cloud watch logs the data transfers that
happen so this is you know who gets
allowed and who does not get allowed i
mean the flow logs is who is allowed and
who's not allowed that kind of detail
and cloud watch gives information about
the data transfer how much data is
getting transferred we can actually pick
unusual data transfers if there is a
certain hike in the graph there's a
sudden hike and something happens at 12
on a regular basis and you weren't
expecting it there's something
suspicious it could be valid backups it
could be a malicious activity as well so
that's how you know by looking at cloud
watch logs and cloud watch dashboard now
let's talk about multiple choice
questions when going for an interview
you might sometimes find yourself that
the company is conducting an online test
based on the score they can put you to a
panelist and then they would take it
forward so we thought we'll also include
multiple choice questions to help you
better handle such situation if you come
across all right when you find yourself
in such situation the key to clear them
is to understand the question properly
read between the lines that's what they
say you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services
mentioned or try to compare and contrast
the answers you can easily read out one
or two answers and then you will be left
with only two answers to decide from you
know so that also helps you with time
and that's all that also helps you with
some precision in your answer so number
one read between the lines number two
compare and contrast the services and
you'll be able to easily weed out the
wrong ones so let's try answering this
question suppose you are a game designer
and you want to develop a game with a
single digit millisecond latency which
of the following database services would
you choose so we know that the following
are database services are good enough
all right and it talks about millisecond
latency that's a key point and the third
thing is it's a game could be a mobile
game it's a game that you are trying to
design and you need a millisecond
latency and it has to be a database all
right so let's talk about the options
available rds rds is a database for sure
is it good for
a game design we'll come back to that
neptune uh neptune is a graph a database
service in amazon so that's kind of out
of the equation and snowball is actually
a storage right it's it's a transport
medium i would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
rds and dynamodb if we need to talk
about rds rds is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an sql
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with
gaming so the only option left is
dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of aws services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so it talks about real time
monitoring firewall manager what does it
provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and aws guard duty is an
threat detection service it does
monitoring it does continuously monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about cloud watch a cloud watch is
a service that helps to track metrics
it's a service that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
i mean we have one more option left
that's uh ebs so what's ebs ebs is a
block storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats
of course it does monitoring so there's
i mean if there is one relation between
cloud watch and guard duty that's
monitoring so easily we can actually
find ourselves slipped towards picking
guard duty but know that guard duty is
only for gaining security insight but
not about gaining aws service inside so
cloudwatch is a service that helps us to
get a system wide or an aws wide or an
account wide and it has number of
metrics we can monitor and get a very
good insight of how a service is
performing be it cpu be it ram b network
utilization beat
connection failures cloudwatch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily all right so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here uh shield aws
massey aws inspector amazon cognito so
let's try to weed out services which are
not relevant to it so what's aws shield
aws shield is actually a service that
provides a ddos mitigation or ddos
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up and mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one aws inspector now aws
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with the improving the security and
compliance of the apps that we deploy in
the cloud so kind of looks like it could
be because it has to do with apps the
last one cognito now cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator to have control access
over web and mobile apps and it's a
service that helps us to sign up and uh
sign in to an mobile and web app so that
very much looks like we found the answer
so cognito is a service that helps web
app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has i mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognito cognito is a service
that helps us to set up sign up sign in
and have access control over the users
who would be using our mobile and web
app all right how about this question
you are an ml engineer or a machine
learning engineer who is on the lookout
for a solution that will discover
sensitive information that your
enterprise stores in aws and then uses
nlp to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the about
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who is looking for a
service that
will help you to discover information at
your enterprise store so we're talking
about storage discover information in
store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's uh identity and
access management so it's identity and
access management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two is already out of
the equation and then the aw is messy we
already had a quick definition
description for aws massey that it's
actually a security service that uses
machine learning kind of looks like it
could be it it's a security service that
uses machine learning and it discovers
and classifies the sensitive information
not only that it does not stop there it
goes beyond and protects the sensitive
data aws massey kind of looks like but
we still have one more option to look at
which is cloud hms cloud hms is also a
security service kind of looks like that
could be the answer as well and it
enables us to generate encryption keys
and save the data so kind of 50 of it
it's a security service it encrypts
helps us protect the data but aws maxi
is right on spot it's a machine learning
service it helps us to classify the data
and also to protect the data so the
answer for this question would be aws
messy so hope you kind of get it how
this is going so first we apply the
thumb rule identify the question that's
being asked read between the lines and
then try to find the service that meets
your requirement then finding the
service is by first weeding out the
wrong ones recollect everything that
you've learned about the service and see
how well that matches with those hints
that you have picked up and if that
doesn't match weed that out then you'll
end up with two just to to decide from
at some point and then it becomes easy
for you to decide click on the question
submit it and then move on to the other
question in your interview all right so
how about this one you are a system
administrator in a company which is
running most of its infrastructure on
aws you are required to
track your users and keep a look on how
your users are being authenticated all
right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage aws users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the aws
resources right you are to give them
permission number one and then i mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it iam
is a service that
helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not so that
helps us to get a track of who is able
to use who's not able to use certain
servers and all that stuff so it kind of
looks like but we have other three
options left let's look at aws firewall
manager just like the name says it's
actually a firewall manager it helps us
to manage multiple firewalls simple as
that and shield is a service it's a
service that's used to protect denial of
service or distributed denial of service
an api gateway is a service that makes
it easy for developers to create publish
maintain and monitor and secure api so i
mean it's completely on the api side
very less on user and how you
authenticate your user we can get that
by looking at the name itself right if
we abbreviate it or if we if you try to
find a definition for the name api
gateway you would get it it has to do
with api but if we aggregate aws iam its
identity and access management pretty
much meets the requirement for the
problem statement about its aws identity
and access management that's the right
answer all right let's look at this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public ip address in order to make
them communicate
with the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using public and private ip
address so this service uses ip address
and then this service helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and to the other instances so
you get the question is it let's pick
the service that helps us achieve it
route 53 route53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or deny no it does
not do that vpc vpc uses public and
private ip address yes so kind of looks
like a vpc helps us
to allow i mean the security in vpc the
security group the network access
control list in a vpc that routing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular ip
address or to a particular service
within the vpc or outside of the vpc so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches uh to the upper
requirement than the amazon vpc gateway
api gateway we know that it's a managed
service that makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor apis and secure api so that
has completely do with api not with ip
cloudfront we know about cloudfront that
it's a content delivery network and it
provides global distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or bulk media or
anything else they can be cached locally
so users can easily access them and
download them easily all right so that's
cloud front now at this point after
looking at all four it looks like vpc is
the right answer and in fact vpc is the
right answer vpc has public ip address
vpc can help us with private ip address
vpc can be used to allow deny connection
based on the security group access
control list and routing table it has so
that's right answer is vpc all right how
about this one this platform as a
service or platform as a db service
provides us with the cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating time
consuming administrative tasks so this
question is very clear it's a db service
we got to look for and it's a service
that can provide automating some of the
time consuming tasks it has to be
resizable at the same time so let's talk
about uh amazon rational database it's a
database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if
that matches the definition that
we've figured out about elastic cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an in-memory data store which
helps in achieving high throughput and
low latency
in memory data store so it's not a
full-blown database and it does not come
with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
no it does not come up with anything
like that yeah we can resize the
capacity as and when needed but
automation
it's not there yet and moreover it's not
a database so that's out of the equation
vpc is
not a recessible one you know once we
have designed vpc it's fixed it can't be
resized so that's out of the equation
and uh amazon glacier glacier is a
storage but not a database right so
that's again of the equation so that tie
is kind of between amazon rational
database service and amazon elastic
cache because they both aid the database
service but elastic cache is not a
full-blown database it actually helps
database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's amazon relational
database that's the one which is a
platform as a service it's the one which
can be resized it's the one which
can be used to automate the
time-consuming administrative tasks all
right let's talk about this one which of
the following is a means for accessing
human researchers or consultants to help
solve a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed amazon elastic
mapreduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has
nothing to do with accessing human
researchers all right let's talk about
mechanical term it's a web service that
provides
a human workforce that's the definition
for it for example automation is good
but not everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be an repetitive task one time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for automation and anything
that requires intelligence right
anything that's a special case right
automation can do repetitive tasks
automation can do precise work but it
has to be repeated tasks the scenario
you know it should have been there
already only then that can be executed
but if it's a new scenario and it
requires uh appropriate addressing then
it requires human thought so we could
hire researchers and consultants who can
help solve a problem using amazon
mechanical turk the other two are
already out of the equation now dev pay
is actually a payment system through
amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is amazon mechanical
turk all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws which of the following
is this aws service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is and container
orchestration service all right the
first one amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one aws
batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances not with
containerized
instances so that's again out of the
equation would light still be a good
time for elastic container service
what's light sale now light scale is a
service it's called as a virtual private
server without a vpc it's called as a
virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage networking capacity it's
actually a server not a container right
so at this point that also becomes out
of the equation so it's amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code amazon easy
to auto scaling easy to auto scaling ec2
is elastic compute cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation aw
is lambda now lambda is a service it's
actually an event driven serverless
computing platform and lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and set up events
correctly to map to that code it's gonna
run seamlessly so that's about lambda it
kind of looks like it could be the
answer because lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
servers by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about aws batch all right batches
service that uh enables id professionals
to run batch job we know that and about
inspector amazon inspector it's actually
a service that helps us to increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance well
that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement and the
question was run code without
provisioning your server and without any
more space for confusion aws lambda is a
service or is the service that runs code
without provisioning and managing
services right the right one would be
aws lambda second part in aws interview
questions if you haven't watched the
first part yet
please go back and watch the first part
we have a lot of interesting questions
there which will better prepare you for
the interview all right let's get
started so in an environment where
there's a lot of automation
infrastructure automation you'll be
posted with this question how can you
add an existing instance to a new auto
scaling group now this is when you are
taking an instance away from the auto
scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to re-add that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's going to
take part in it right only then the auto
scaling is going to count it has part of
it it's not a straight uh procedure you
know when you remove them you know it
doesn't get automatically re-added i've
had worked with some clients so when
their developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like i said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance uh to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the uh instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to auto scaling group
right if you have multiple auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five auto
scaling groups for five different
application you know you're going to be
posted with five different auto scaling
groups and then you would select
the auto scaling the appropriate auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular auto scaling group while
adding to the auto scaling group if you
want to change the instance type you
know that's possible as well sometimes
uh when you want to add the instance
back to the auto skilling group there
would be requirement that you change the
instance type to a better one to a
better family to the better instance
type you could do that at that time and
after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step uh process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they're dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating an vm into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth
moving the instance to the cloud given
the additional bills and results
features available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes you know cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and supply transparency is
this application in high demand you know
is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are a few things that
needs to be considered before we move
the application to the cloud and then if
uh the application does the application
needs to be provisioned immediately is
that an urge is there an urge to
provision the application immediately
that's something that needs to be
considered if the
application requires to go online if the
application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on premises
procuring or buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying the softwares buying the
license related to it it's going to take
time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so the
application cannot wait you know waiting
means uh you know workforce productivity
loss is it so we would want to
immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is a urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if
the
the software or if the product that
you're launching it requires hardware it
requires an updated hardware all the
time that's not going to be possible in
on-premises we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time in
on-premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardwares
only then they can keep themselves up
going in the market so they constantly
the cloud providers are constantly
updating their hardwares and if you want
to be benefited of your application
wants to be benefited by the constant
upgrading of the hardwares making sure
the hardware is as latest as possible
the software version the licensing is as
latest as possible then that's a
candidate to be moved to the cloud and
if the application does not want to go
through any risk if the application is
very sensitive to failures if the
application is very much tied to the
revenue of the company and you don't
want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business uh agility you know
moving to
the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails amazon makes sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is rto and rpo in aws they are
essentially disaster recovery terms when
you're planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about rto and
rpo now what's the rto what's the rpo in
your environment or how to define rto
how do you define rpo or some general
questions that get asked rto is recovery
time objective rto stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is uh
in the future right how much time
is it going to take to fix and bring
everything to normal so that's rto on
the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data loss your company is willing to
accept as measured in time rpo always
refers to the backups the number of
backups the the frequency of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the latest backup
right and if the latest backup was
before 12 hours you have lost the in
between 12 hours of
data data storage right so rpo is the
acceptable amount if the company wants
less rpo rpo is 1r then you should be
planning on taking backups every one
hour if rpo is 12 hours then you should
be planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how rpo and rto you know
helps disaster recovery the fourth
question you could get asked is if you'd
like to transfer huge amount of data
which is the best option among snowball
snowball edge and snowmobile again this
is a question that get asked if the
company is dealing with a lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with the migrating
data into the cloud i'm talking about a
huge amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now aws snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified aws region on the other hand
aws snowball edge adds additional
computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball edge has a compute function
attached to it snow mobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is aws cloud formation different from
aws elastic beanstalk you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides and simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and elastic beanstalk
gives us an small contained environment
in which we can run our application and
cloud formation supports the
infrastructure needs of many different
types of application like the
enterprise application the legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock it's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bean stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using uh cloud formation to
manage their infrastructure using or if
they're using infrastructure or any of
the infrastructure as a code uh services
then you would definitely face this
question what are the elements of an aws
cloud formation uh template so it has
four or five basic uh elements right and
the template is in the form of json or
in yaml format all right so it has
parameters it has outputs it has data it
has resources and then the
format or the format version or the file
format version for the cloud formation
template so parameter is nothing but
it actually lets you to specify the type
of ec2 instance that you want the type
of rds that you want all right so ec2 is
an umbrella rds is an umbrella and
parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rds are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the rds service so
that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want to output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted in the
result section so we can simply go and
look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource rds is a resource and s3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and nat gateway
is a resource vpc is a reserve so you
see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
aws cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have a version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0909
2010 that's the latest version number
you'll be able to find that on the top
of the cloud formation template and that
version number defines the capabilities
of the cloud formation template so just
need to make sure that it's the latest
all the time still talking about cloud
formation this is another classic
question what happens when one of the
resource in a stack cannot be created
successfully well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful
when the cloud formation cannot you know
go forward cloud formation cannot create
additional resources because we have
reached the elastic
ip limits elastic ip limit per region is
five right and if you have already used
five ips and a cloud formation is trying
to buy
three more ips you know we've hit the
soft limit till we fix that with amazon
cloudformation will not be able to you
know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with a missing ec2 ami as
well if an ami is included in the
template and but the ami is not actually
present then cloud formation is going to
search for the mi and because it's not
present it's going to roll back and
delete all the resources that it created
so that's what cloud formation does it
simply rolls back all the resources that
it created i mean if it sees a failure
it would simply roll back all the
resources that it created and this
feature actually simplifies the system
administration and layout solutions
built on top of aws cloud formation so
at any point we know that there are no
orphan resources in the in in our
environment you know because something
did not work or because there was an you
know cloud formation executed some there
are no orphan resources in our account
at any point we can be sure that if
cloud formation is launching a resource
and if it's going to fail and it's going
to come back and delete all the
resources it's created so there are no
orphan resources in our account now
let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store again if the
environment deals with a lot of
automation you could be thrown this
question how can you automate easy to
backup using ebs it's actually a six
step process to automate the ec2 backups
we'll need to write a script to automate
the below steps uh using aws api and
these are the steps that should be found
in the scripts first to get the list of
instances and then and then the script
that we are writing should be able to
connect to aws using the api and list
the amazon abs volumes that are attached
locally to the instance and then it
needs to list the snapshots of each
volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because you have captured the latest and
10 snapshot coverage is enough for you
and then the fifth point is to create a
snapshot of each volume create a new
snapshot of each volume and then delete
the old snapshot anytime a new snapshot
gets created the oldest snapshot of the
list needs to go away so we need to
include options we need to include
scripts in our script lines in our
script that make sure that it's deleting
the older snapshots which are older than
the retention period that we are
mentioning another question that you
could see in the interview be it written
interview beat online interview or beat
and telephonic or face-to-face interview
is what's the difference between ebs and
instant store let's talk about ebs first
ebs is kind of permanent storage the
data in it can be restored at a later
point when we save data in ebs the data
lives even after the lifetime of the ec2
instance for example we can stop the
instance and the data is still going to
be present in ebs we can move the ebs
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so abs is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine ebs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of the
machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with eba so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is ebs is permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using ebs and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of efs like ebs
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take efs to efs backup solution efs
does not support snapshot like ebs efs
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for efs elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one efs to another efs and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
efs and this can be automated but any
data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole ef is is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an
one-step configuration it's a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve efs to
efs backup the first thing is to sign in
to the aws management console and under
efs or click on efs to efs restore
button from the services list and from
there we can use the region selector in
the console navigation bar to select the
actual region in which we want to work
on and from there i'll ensure that we
have selected the right template you
know some of the templates would be you
know efs to efs backup granular backups
incremental
backups right so there are some
templates the kind of backups that you
want to take do you want to take grant
alert do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an efs to efs backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with
a data management there are easy options
to create snapshots but deleting
snapshots is
not always an you know click button or
an single step configuration so you
might be facing a question like how do
you auto delete old snapshots and the
procedure is like this now as best
practice we will take snapshots of ebs
volume to s3 all snapshots get stored in
s3 we know that now and we can use aws
ops automator to automatically handle
all snapshots the ops automator service
it allows us to create copy delete ebs
snapshots so there are cloud formation
templates available for aws ops
automator and this automator
template will scan the environment and
it would take snapshots it would you
know copy the snapshot from one region
to another region if you want you know
if you're setting up a dr environment
and not only that based on the retention
period that we
create it's going to delete the
snapshots which are older than the
retention period so life or managing
snapshot is made a lot easier because of
this ops automator cloud formation
template moving into questions and
elastic load balancer this again could
be an
question in the interview what are the
different types of load balancers in aws
and what's their use case what's the
difference between them and as of now as
we speak there are three types of load
balancers which are available in aws the
first one being application load
balancer just like the name says the
application load balancer works on the
application layer and deals with the
http and https request and
it it also supports part based routing
for example simplylearn.com slash some
webpage simplylearn.com
another website so it's going to direct
the path based on the slash value that
you give in the urls that's path based
routing so it supports that and not only
that it can support a port based colon
8080 colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know
based on that port also it can take a
routing decision and that's what
application load balancer does on the
other hand we have network load balancer
and the network load balancer makes
routing decisions at the transport level
it's faster because it has very less
thing to work on it works on lower osi
layer it works on a lower layer so it
has very less information to work with
than compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path-based or
port-based routing it does simple
routing and because of it it's faster
and then we have a classic load balancer
which is kind of expiring as we speak
amazon is discouraging people using
classic load balancer but there are
companies which are still using classic
load balancer they are the ones who were
the first one to step in to amazon when
classic load balancer was the first load
balancer or the only load balancer
available at that point so it supports
http https tcp ssl protocol and it has a
fixed relationship between a load
balance report and the container port so
initially we only have classic load
balancer and then
at after some point amazon said instead
of having one load balancer address all
type of traffic we're going to have a
two load balances called as the child
from the classic two load balancer and
one is going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balancers talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just spoke
about it application load balancer is
used if we need a flexible application
management and tls termination and
network load balancer if we require
extreme performance and the load
balancing should happen on based on
static ips for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from
easy to classic network now this is an
older version of vpc or this is what was
present before vpc was created easy to
classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of the
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall in aws we cannot
avoid discussion talking about waff web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use aws off in monitoring your
aws applications waff or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and vaf helps
us control which traffic source your
application should be allowed or a block
which traffic from a certain source and
which source or which traffic from a
certain source should be allowed or
blocked your application with waff we
can also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has
i mean content management application it
has a separate type of attack so based
on the application type we can identify
a pattern and create rules that would
actually block that attack based on the
rule that we create and waff can be used
for three cases you know the first one
is allow all requests and then a block
all request and count all requests for a
new policy so it's also an monitoring
and management service which actually
counts all the policies or counts all
the requests that matches a particular
policy that we create and some of the
characteristics we can mention in awsof
are the origin ips and the strings that
appear in the request we can allow block
based on origin ip allow block based on
strings that appear in the request we
can allow block or count based on the
origin country length of the request
yeah we can block and count the presence
of malicious scripts in an connection
you know we can count the request
headers or we can allow block a certain
request header and we can count the
presence of a malicious sql code in a
connection that we get and that want to
reach our application still talking
about security what are the different
aws im categories we can control using
aws iam we can do the following one is
create and manage im users and once the
user database gets bigger and bigger we
can create and manage them in groups and
in im we can use it
to manage the security credentials kind
of setting the complexity of the
password you know setting additional
authentications you know like mfa and
you know rotating the passwords no
resetting the password there are a few
things we could do with iam and finally
we can create policies that actually
grants access to aws services and
resources another question you will see
is what are the policies that you can
set for your users password so some of
the policies that we can set for the
user password is at the minimum length
or you know the complexity of the
password by at least having one number
or one special characters in the
password so that's one and then the
requirement of a specific character
types including you know uppercase
lowercase number and
characters so it becomes very hard for
somebody else to guess what the password
would be and and try to hack them so we
can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity in the password and then
we can set an automatic expiration of
the password so after a certain time the
user is forced to create a new password
so the password is not still old and
easy to guess in the environment and we
can also set settings like the user
should contact the admin i mean when the
password is about to expire so you know
you can get a hold of how the user is
setting their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards or there are few things that
we can control and set for the users
when the users are setting or recreating
the password another question that could
be posted in an interview so to
understand your understanding of im is
what's the difference between an iem
role and an im user let's talk about iem
user let's start small and then go big
or let's start simple and then talk
about the complex one the iem user has a
permanent long-term credential and it's
used to interact directly with aws
services and on the other hand iem role
is an iem entity that defines a set of
permissions for making aws service
requests so iem user is an permanent
credential and role are temporary
credentials and iem user has full access
to all aws iem functionalities and with
role trusted entities such as iem users
application or aws services
assume the role so when an im user is
given an
permission you know it sticks within the
iem user but with roles we can give
permissions to applications we can give
permissions to users in the same account
in a different account the corporate id
we can give permissions to ec2 s3 rds
vpc and lot more role is wide and im
user is is not so wide you know it's
very constrained only for that i am user
let's talk about managed policies in aws
managed policies there are two types you
know customer managed and amazon managed
so manage policies are im resources that
express permissions using the iam policy
language we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the im user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so i can
have like three services four services
point to a particular policy and if i
edit that particular policy it's gonna
reflect on those three or four services
so anything that i allow is going to be
allowed for those four services anything
that i denied is going to be denied for
the four services imagine what would be
without the im managed policy will have
to go and specifically allow deny on
those different instances four or five
times depending on the number of
instances that we have so like i said
there are two types of managed policies
one is managed by us which is customer
managed policies and then the other is
managed by aws which is aws managed
policy this question can you give an
example of an im policy and a policy
summary this is actually to test how
well versed are you with the aws console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to grant access to add update and delete
objects from a specific folder now in
this case name of the folder is example
folder and it's present in a bucket
called example bucket so this is an iam
policy on the other hand the policy
summary is a list of access level
resources and conditions for each
service defined in a policy so im policy
is all about one particular resource and
the policy summary is all about multiple
resources with im policy it was only
talking about s3 bucket and one
particular s3 bucket here it talks about
cloud formation template cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them that's what policy summary is all
about another question could be like
this what's the use case of iam and how
does im help your business too important
or primary work of im is to help us
manage iam users and their access it
provides a secure access to multiple
users to their appropriate aws resources
so that's one it does and the second
thing it does is manage access for
federated users federated users or non
iam users and through iam we can
actually allow and provide secured
access to resources in our aws account
to our employees without the im user no
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the facebook
credential google credential amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party
identity management right so we could
actually trust them and we could give
them access to our account based on the
trust relationship that we have built
with the other identity of systems right
so two things one is manage users and
their access
for manage iam user and their access in
our aws environment and second is
manage access for federated users who
are non-iam users and more importantly
im is a free service and with that
will only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the im username and
password that we create all right lets
now talk about some of the questions in
route 53
one classic question that could be asked
in an interview is what is the
difference between latency based routing
and
geodns or jio based dns routing now the
geo-based dns routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between
networks and
data centers now latency based routing
is used where you want to give your
customers the lowest latency as possible
so that's when we would use latency
based routing and on the other hand the
geo based routing is when we want to
direct customers to different websites
based on the country they are browsing
from you know you could have you know
two different or three different
websites for the same url you know take
amazon the shopping website for example
when we go to
amazon.com from in the us it directs us
to the us web page where the products
are different the currency is different
right and the flag and a couple of other
advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from india it gets directed to the
amazon.com indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a geo
based routing another use case of jio
based routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the dns requests sorry if you should
handle all the
requests you know from a country within
the country then you would do geo-based
routing now you wouldn't direct the
customer to a server which is in another
country right you would direct the
customer to a server which is very local
to them that's another use case of
geo-based routing and like i said for
latency based routing the whole goal or
aim is to achieve minimum end user
latency if you are hired for the
architect role and
if that requires working lot on the dns
then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted zone a domain is
actually a collection of
data describing a self-contained
administrative and technical unit on the
internet right so for example you know
simplylearn.com is actually a domain on
the other hand hosted zone is actually
an container that holds information
about how you want to route traffic on
the internet to a specific domain for
example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted zone
whereas simplylearn.com is an domain so
in other words in hosted zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it lms is a prefix here ftp is a prefix
mail mail.simplylearn.com as a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question
from another classic question from route
53 would be how does amazon drop 53
provide high availability and low
latency the way amazon rav53 provides
high availability and low latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an dns server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the dns providers there
are dns providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with amazon amazon is a
globally distributed dns provider it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has optimal locations it has got
global servers or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide high availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
high availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in aws config a
classic question would be how does aws
config work along with aws cloudtrail
aws cloudtrail actually records user api
activity on the account and you know any
http https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any api calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloud trail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your cloud environment on
the other hand config is an
point in time configuration details of
your resources for example at a given
point what are all the resources that
were present in my environment what are
all the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in aws
conflict right so with that information
you can always answer the question what
did my aws resource look like at a given
point in time that question gets
answered when we use aws config on the
other hand with cloudtrail uh you can
answer the question i mean by looking at
the cloud trail or with the help of
cloudtrail you can easily answer the
question who made an apa call to modify
this resource that's answered by
cloudtrail and with the cloud trail we
can detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and who did that
configuration let's say uh there
happened to be a downtime and you want
to identify let's say there happen to be
a downtime and you want to identify who
made that
change in the environment you can simply
look at cloudtrail and find out who made
the change and if you want to look at
how the environment looks like before
the change you can always look at aws
config can aws configure or aws config
aggregate data across different aws
accounts yes it can now this question is
actually to test whether you have used
aws config or not i know some of the
services are very local is it some of
these services are availability zone
specific some of them are regional
specific and some of them are global
services in amazon and though some of
the services are region services you
still can do some changes you know add
some configuration to it and collect
regional data in it for example s3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an s3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to cloudwatch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
global by default but you can do some
changes and make it global similarly aws
config is a service that's a region
based service but still you can make it
act globally you can aggregate data
across a different region and different
accounts in an aws config and deliver
the updates from different accounts to
one s3 bucket and can access it from
there aws config also works or
integrates seamlessly with sns topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer wants to understand how well
you know that fact by asking this
question how are reserved instances
different from on
db instances reserved instances and
on-demand instances are exactly the same
when it comes to their function but they
only differ based on how they are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low
per hour pricing because we're paying
upfront it's generally said that
reserved incidence is 75 percentage
cheaper than on-demand instance and
amazon gives you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year on the other hand
on-demand instances are built on an
oddly early price talking about auto
scaling how will you understand the
different types of auto scaling the
interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and y the two types of
scaling as you would know now vertical
and horizontal and in vertical scaling
we can vertically scale up the master
database with a couple of clicks all
right so that's vertical scaling
vertical scaling is keeping the same
node and making it bigger and bigger if
previously it was running on t2 micro
now we would like to run it on m3 two
times large instance previously it had
one virtual cpu one gigabit now it's
going to have eight virtual cpu and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one vm now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 vms right
that's horizontal scaling so database
can only be scaled vertically and there
are 18 different types of instances we
can resize our rds to right so this is
true for rds mysql postgres sql mariadb
oracle microsoft sql servers there are
18 type of instances we can vertically
scale up to on the other hand horizontal
scaling are good for replicas so they
are read only replicas we're not going
to touch the master
database we're not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling only with amazon aurora and i
can add additional read replicas i can
add up to 15 read replicas for amazon
aurora and up to five re-replicas for
rds mysql postgres sql and marie db rds
instances and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right i read only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking in to increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you are looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment still talking
about database this is another good
question you can expect in the interview
what is the maintenance window in amazon
rds will your db instance be available
during the maintenance event alright so
this is really to test how well you have
understood the sla how well you have
understood the amazon rdas uh the
failover mechanism of amazon rdas stuff
like that so audio's maintenance window
it lets you decide
when a db instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the db
instance will be available during that
event because you're going to have
primary and secondary right so when that
upgrade happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach
consistency within a second and
sometimes when you write and when you're
you know trying to read immediately
chances that you you would still be
reading the old data that's eventual
consistency on the other hand there is
another consistency model called the
strong consistency or strongly
consistent read where there is going to
be a delay in writing the data you know
making sure the data is written in all
places but it guarantees one thing that
is once you have done a write and then
you're trying to do a read it's going to
make sure that it's going to show you
the updated data not the old data and
you can be guaranteed of it that it is
going to show the updated data and not
the old data that's strongly consistent
still talking about database talking
about nosql dynamodb or nosql database
which is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of query
functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using global secondary index
and local secondary indexes a primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite
partition sort key in other words a
dynamodb indexes a composite partition
sort key as a partition key element and
a sort key element and by holding the
partition key you know when doing a
search or when doing a query by holding
the partition key element constant we
can search across the sort key element
to retrieve the other items in that
table and the composite partition sort
key should be a combination of user id
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition sort key is made
of let's look at some of the multiple
choice questions you know sometimes some
companies would have an uh written test
or an mcq type online test before they
call you for at the first level or
before they call you for the second
level so these are some classical
questions that companies asked or
companies ask in their multiple choice
online questions let's look at this
question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have aws step functions amazon
mq amazon simple queue service amazon
simple notification service let's read
the question again as a developer using
this pay-per-use service so the service
that we are looking for is a
pay-per-view service you can send store
and retrieve messages between two
software components kind of like a queue
there so what would be the right answer
it would be amazon simple queue service
now amazon simple queue service is the
one that's used to decouple at the
environment you know it breaks the tight
coupling and then it introduces
decoupling in that environment by
providing a queue or by inserting a
queue between two software components
let's look at this other question if you
would like to host a real-time audio and
video conferencing application on aws
it's an audio and video conferencing
application on aws this service provides
you with a secure and easy to use
application what is this service let's
look at the options they are amazon
chime amazon workspace amazon mq amazon
app stream well you might tend to look
at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference but it's actually
for a different purpose is actually
amazon chime that lets you create chat
and create a chat board and then
collaborate with the security of the aws
services so it lets you do the audio
it's lets you do the video conference
all supported by aws security features
it's actually amazon chime let's look at
this question as your company's aw
solution architect you are in charge of
designing thousands of individual jobs
which are similar which of the following
service best serves your requirement aws
ec2 autoscaling aws snowball aws
fargate aws badge let's read the
question again as your company's aws
solution architect you are in charge of
designing thousands of individual jobs
which are similar it looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an storage transport service
ec2 auto scaling is you know in
introducing scalability and elasticity
in the environment and aws fargate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are similar aws batch it's the right
answer but let's look at the other one
you are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train machine learning
models in aws which among the following
are we referring to so we have amazon
sage maker and aws deep lens amazon
comprehend aws device farm let's read
the question again you are a machine
learning engineer and you're looking for
a service that helps you build and train
machine learning models in aws which
among the following are referred here
the answer is sage maker it provides
every developer and data scientist with
the ability to build train and deploy
machine learning models quickly that's
what sagemaker does now for you to be
familiar with you know the the products
i would recommend you to you know simply
go through the
product description you know there's one
page available on amazon that explains
all the products a quick neat and simple
that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it a db service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with great confidence so the
answer is amazon sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and data scientists the ability to build
a train and deploy machine learning
models quickly as possible all right
let's look at this one let's say that
you are working for your company's id
team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the aws resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the aws resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it amazon vpc amazon iam amazon
inspector amazon elastic load balancing
amazon vpc is a networking service
amazon iam is an username password
authentication amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the uh
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross platform video
game development engine that supports pc
xbox playstation ios and android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on amazon's servers so
we have amazon game lift amazon green
grass amazon lumber yard amazon uh
sumerian let's read the question again
this cross-platform video game
development engine that supports pc xbox
playstation ios and android platforms
allows developers to build and host
their games on amazon servers the answer
is amazon lumberyard this lumberyard is
an free
aaa gaming engine deeply integrated with
aws and twitch with full source this
lumbar yard provides a growing set of
tools that helps you create and highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your aws
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have aws budgets we have aws
cost explorer we have amazon work mail
we have amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost explorer now cost
explorer is an option in the amazon
console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage the aws cost over time
who's spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question you
are a chief cloud architect at your
company and how can you automatically
monitor and adjust computer resources to
ensure maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources so
we have a cloud formation as a service
we have aws aurora as a solution we have
aws auto scaling and amazon api gateway
let's read the question again you're the
chief cloud architect at your company
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust computer resources how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is
autoscaling right that's a basic service
and solution architect
course is it auto scaling is the service
that helps us to easily adjust monitor
and ensure the maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources it
does that by automatically scaling the
environment to handle the inputs let's
look at this question as a database
administrator you will use a service
that is used to set up and manage
databases such as mysql mariadb and
postgres sql which service are we
referring to amazon aurora amazon
elastic cache aws rds aws database
migration service amazon aurora is
amazon's flavor of
the rds service and elastic cache is is
the caching service provided by amazon
they are not full-fledged database and
database migration service just like the
name says it helps to migrate the
database from on premises to the cloud
and from one a database flavor to
another database flavor amazon rds is
the service is the console is the
service it's the umbrella service that
helps us to set up manage databases like
mysql money db and postgres sql it's
amazon rts let's look at this last
question a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages to onto
google facebook windows and apple
through apis or aws management console
you will use the following service so
the options are aws cloudtrail aws
config amazon chime aws simple
notification service it says a part of
your marketing work requires you to push
messages it's dealing with pushing
messages to google facebook windows and
apple through apis or aws management
console you will use the following
service it's simple notification service
simple notification service is an
message pushing a service and sqs is
pulling similarly sns is pushing right
here it talks about a pushing system
that pushes messages to google facebook
windows and apple through api and it's
going to be a simple notification system
or a simple notification service i hope
this helps you in your interview with
that we have reached the end of this
complete aws tutorial
i hope you enjoyed this video do like
and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]
you